In this course, you will learn
how to design and use databases,
you will create a graphical
Windows application that can
display and modify data from a
MySQL database server. Shad
Sluiter is your instructor for
this course, he is a professor
of computer science and software
development at Grand Canyon
University.
Hi, in this video, I'm going to
show you how to create this
application that's on the
screen. This will be a Visual
Studio project. And we are going
to focus in on working with
databases. So let's look at the
features of what we're going to
build. And then I'm going to
give you the outline of the
different subjects that we're
going to cover some of the
technical things that you'll
learn. And then finally, we'll
get into the part where we start
building it. So let's look at
the features first. And then
we'll get into what we actually
have to learn some of the
features, you can see on the
application that we have a
database. So that's the main
feature. And we are going to
have a bunch of songs. So you
can see that I have albums on
the top table here. And when I
click on an album, I have a
preview of the album cover. And
then in the bottom part, we can
see the different songs that are
on that album. So for instance,
here we got help, and have a
video player over here.
And so we can listen to The
Beatles, as they call for help.
So if I choose the other song
here, you'll see that it'll
automatically switch, it looks
to me like that one's
unavailable. And then we get
Ticket to Ride. And I have to
suffer through an ad. So this is
just a YouTube player. It is not
anything saved to my computer.
Alright, so now I'm getting
Ticket to Ride like I asked for
it to begin with. Now I can also
delete some of these things. So
for instance, if I wanted for
some reason to get rid of Abbey
Road, I can try the delete
button up here. And then I get a
confirm message that says Are
you sure you want to delete
number three, as you can see,
album number three is listed
here. And I don't actually want
to delete this right now. Okay,
so now let's talk about what are
some of the features and some of
the programming that you're
going to learn. First of all,
you can see that we're going to
build a database, let's see what
this database looks like. You
can see I have a table here
called album, another one called
track, and I filled in some data
for you, we're going to be
working with MySQL and this tool
called MySQL Workbench. And so
you can see that the table
definition here shows that we
have a foreign key relationship
between the album and all of the
tracks that are on that album.
So I will take you through the
process of setting up a database
and defining the different
fields and then creating this
link between the two tables
called a foreign key. So this
video is targeted at people who
know some programming, but are
not really familiar with
databases to a great deal. And
so what we're going to do is
focus in on how to build this
database, and to write the
queries that can make this
application work. My name is
shad Sluiter, and I teach
software development at Grand
Canyon University in Phoenix,
Arizona. So in this course,
you're going to see the emphasis
on working with databases. So
I'm teaching a course on SQL and
on Mongo right now. And so you
get to see the benefit of what
we're doing in class. If you
would like to look at the full
series of this thing, you can
either subscribe to the channel
that you're looking at now on
YouTube, or you can see the more
extensive version on steady
coding.org, which is another
website. So I welcome you to
come back, because people that
are in my classroom are becoming
professional software developers
and getting great jobs. And so
you could do that too. Okay, so
let's get into the first phase
of this. So phase number one is
build the database. phase number
two is to build the application.
And then phase three is to
connect those two things
together. So we're starting off
here at the beginning, which
could take a little while, we're
going to build a database. So
what we're going to do first is
design the album table. And then
after we have the album table
working, we will go and try to
make it connect to the
application. And then we'll come
back to the track and we'll add
the song tracks later. So we're
going to build this application
kind of piecewise. So we'll get
very basic to start with and
then more advanced as we get
through this series of videos.
So let's start with building a
new database. Okay, so let's get
started with the tools that
we're going to need. So in this
first part, we're going to need
to have a SQL Server. So there
are various types of SQL
databases that you can install.
We're going to be using MySQL
which is free it's open source,
it runs on multiple platforms.
However, there are other
alternatives besides MySQL even
though it's the most popular and
widely used database probably in
the planet. You
could use Postgres, which
apparently has more features,
you could use Microsoft SQL,
which is a very scalable and is
used by a lot of enterprise
customers, you could go to
Oracle, they have a very
expensive system. And you could
probably find others as well.
But MySQL is what we're choosing
because it has great tools, and
it's free. So the tool that
we're going to be using is MAMP,
Ma, MP that stands for
Macintosh, Apache, MySQL, and
PHP. Now, don't let the
Macintosh part scare you away,
because if we were to go look at
the downloads, we're going to
see that the first version that
they recommend is for Windows.
So they have a Windows version
and a Mac version, which is
really good, because in my
classroom, I have students that
have both types of operating
systems on their computer. So
we're going to install MAMP. And
we're going to wait for the
download to finish. And then
when we set it up, we will not
choose MAMP Pro, but we will
just use the free version, that
will work just great for our
purposes. Another tool that
we'll be using in this project
is MySQL Workbench. And you can
see the download page here. Now
MySQL Workbench is used for
arranging more complex
databases. And so we won't see
this for the first part of the
tutorial, because we're only
going to have a single table to
get started with. But just to
let you know that this is
coming, we will be using this
eventually, to create the
application that will make this
media player work, we're going
to be using Visual Studio
version 2022. And we'll be
creating a Windows desktop
application. So we'll get to
that part. When we get to the
application. We're first of all
going to build the database
though. Okay, so now I have
skipped ahead, I have installed
MAMP. I have chosen not to use
MAMP Pro, so I unchecked one of
those boxes. And now I have this
application up and running. Now
I want to start this. So I'm
going to click Start servers.
And you're going to see two
different little green dots up
here, one for Apache, and the
second one for MySQL server. Now
we could care less about Apache
server for this application.
This is for hosting websites.
And this is not going to be a
web application. However, we're
going to be using a SQL server
so that way, we have the ability
to handle the database. And so
that's why I installed MAMP. Now
there are other packages that
you could use. If this doesn't
work out for you, you could use
Wempe wa MP, which is for
Windows, you could use XAMPP x a
MP, you can search for that it
has the same functionalities
with different menus in
different places. Another tool,
which is really good that is not
required you to install anything
is the USB web server. So the
second link on the page here
actually has a free version of
what USB web server is. And you
can download this. And you can
literally run it from a USB
stick, you could run it on any
computer lab or you don't have
access to install software. And
it will do the same features as
what we're going to do in the
video. So take your pick, I'm
going to be using MAMP. And
that's what the tutorials will
be easiest to follow it. So go
ahead and pick MAMP if you can
otherwise choose one of the
alternatives. Okay, so now we're
back. Now that we got the
application running, let's go
and choose this button called
Open start page. And you're
going to see that the website
load opens to localhost slash
MAMP. So let's go to tools. And
I want to choose PHP myadmin.
And this will bring up all of
the databases that I have
installed on this server. So you
can see over on the left side, I
have music, MySQL and a few
other things. So the only thing
that we're going to focus in on
here is this one called music.
And since that I've already
created this application, I have
some data in it, you can skip
ahead, if you know how to do all
of this, we need to create a
table and fill it with some
data. But I'm going to do that
right now. So you can see the
process. The first thing I'm
going to do is I'm going to
create a new database. So I have
music, I'm going to create a new
one. So let's click the link at
the top. And this one, I'm just
going to call it music two,
because I'm going to recreate
the same application. The
language that you choose, of
course, is probably English. If
you're watching this video, I'm
just going to choose the general
text that we have here. Now we
are supposed to create a table
and the first table we're going
to create is called albums. And
now we have to decide how many
columns we're going to put in
the albums table. Okay, so now
I'm going to cheat and I'm going
to look back to what I actually
created in this application. So
here's the other tab. You can
see I'm going to create 1234566
columns, and I'm going to have
different data types in each
column. So let's change this
number to a six and then choose
Create table. Let's click the Go
button.
The first thing we're going to
do is name the six columns. So
just going straight down the
left side of the form I'm going
to type in ID and a database ID
is always the first item it's a
number that
has a unique identifier for each
record. The next thing we're
going to put in is the album
title. And I'm using an
underscore to separate the
words, you don't have to use
underscores. But it's a pattern
that a lot of people use. I'm
going to use artists year image,
Name and Description to be the
rest of these. So these were
going to be the six columns that
describe each album in our
database. Now let's take a look
at the next item here. So the
type, so every one of these
right now says int, which stands
for integer. Now, integers are
numbers, of course. Now if I
want to have something besides
an integer, I can just select it
from here, I'm going to choose a
text version. So var char and
text are two two choices. Let's
take a look at the hints to see
why we would pick one or the
other. So var char is a variable
length, character string. And it
is used for things like words or
titles, so it fits perfectly
with the album title. And then
the next item over here, we can
say how many characters so let's
say 100 letters is the length of
our title.
Now for the rest of these, we're
going to add some more details.
So for the artist, this would
also make sense to use a
variable character length var
char, we've got a year which
will leave right at integer
that's easy to work with, we
could pick date, but year is
pretty simple to work with.
We're going to work with an
image name, which is a URL. So
it's the it's the HTTP slash
Wikipedia address that we're
going to get images from. And so
this could be pretty long, let's
leave it at, let's say 1000
characters for the maximum
length. Then for the
description, let's change this
to text. Now the difference
between text and var char is
kind of subtle. So text is
usually used if you have a large
section like a text area on a
webpage, where you expect to see
paragraphs of information. Var
char usually as a single line
for like a name or an address or
something rather short. So both
of them are saving letters in in
a format that looks the same to
us. But they are different in
the computer's mind. So text
works well for description.
Okay, so this thing is ready to
go. So down here at the bottom,
you can see that there's a save
button, let's click it and cross
our fingers. So as soon as I
click save, you can see now I
have switched to the tab called
structure. So structure tells me
what my database is made of. So
you can see that we have all of
these data types that we just
created. And there's going to be
no data. So if I choose Browse,
we're going to see that the
column headers are here. And
there's actually no data in the
database yet, I'm gonna change
one item that I forgot to do
previously, the first item is an
ID number. And that is supposed
to be a unique number that the
computer generates. So I'm going
to click the Change Icon. And
let's see why I would want to
change that. So I'm going to
switch over here to this item
that says auto increment, a
underscore I've had is not
artificial intelligence, that's
auto increment. And when I
select it, it's going to
automatically choose the next
number available for whatever
record I put in. So the first
one will be record number one,
and then two, and then so on. It
never deletes or goes backwards.
So it'll go to infinity
eventually. But we just want to
make sure it's unique. So let's
say let's click save. Now as
soon as I click save, you notice
there's a new icon here, it's
got a little key. So that tells
me that the ID is now a primary
key, which is important, it
means that it is the only item
really, that has to be filled
in, in all six columns. And it
will be used to connect to this
table to other tables later on.
So that's enough to get us
started with our database, let's
add some data.
So as I tried to add data, I
click on the Insert tab. And now
I'm going to fill in some items,
I'm going to leave the ID blank
because the computer is going to
automatically provide the next
number in the database. So the
first one will be one. So we'll
leave it blank. The title for
our album is Abbey Road, and
it's done by the Beatles, and
the date is 1961. Now let's see
if we can get some information
from the internet to fill in the
other items. So I've got a
description and an image URL.
Let's just use our friends at
Wikipedia to help us out. So I'm
going to search in Google for
Wikipedia and Abbey Road. And
let's bring up the article that
tells us about Abbey Road. So
first of all the image let's
take a copy of that. So I'm
going to right click it and
choose Copy Image address. And
let's switch back into our
database. And now let's paste it
here. So let's see Ctrl V and
you can see that the URL to this
image is from uploads at
Wikipedia. So I don't have to
save this to my disk. I'm just
going to rely on whatever's
hosted
at Wikipedia, so if they delete
this picture from the website,
my application will no longer be
able to show the image. So it
saves me space, but then I have
to rely on them not to delete my
image. Let's scroll down a
little bit. And you can see the
last item here is a text field.
And we're supposed to add a
description. Well, here's a nice
description, let's just copy the
first part of the Wikipedia
article. And let's paste it into
our database. And now I don't
have to type anything. Now I'm
going to click go. So it says
here at the top that one row has
been inserted. And it tells me
the SQL statement that was just
executed, you notice it says
Insert into has the table name,
then it mentions all of the
column names here. And then the
next statement is values. And
then below that, you can see all
of the text. So if I click on
Browse, I should be able to go
back and see that now I have one
item called Abbey Road. If I
want to see one of these in
detail, I can just double click
it. And you can now see that I
have a whole bunch of data in
the description, which takes
multiple lines. So that is how
you can fill in a table. If you
would like to look at the full
series of this thing, you can
either subscribe to the channel
that you're looking at now on
YouTube, or you can see the more
extensive version on study
coding.org, which is another
website. So here's your
homework, I want you to fill in
about a half a dozen different
albums. So I'm picking the
Beatles, you can choose any one
you like. But we need to have
something that we can search
for. So for the next video, I'm
going to show you how to query
data and you can search for
certain keywords or filter it.
So come back again, and we'll
continue on our database
application.
Hi, and this second video of a
series we're going to continue
to explore building a SQL
database application. Here's the
index of all of the things we're
going to learn. In the first
video we worked through creating
our first database. In this
video, we're going to start to
write some queries using the SQL
language. In the future, we're
going to talk about the front
end connecting our database to
that front end, doing some
searches inserting records,
creating foreign keys, joining
tables together, creating what's
called UML diagrams, making
compound queries or multiple
queries in one step, we're going
to delete items from the
database. And then finally, at
the very end of this course,
we're talking about features
that we didn't get to, but you
could probably explore. So this
whole series here is available,
not only here where you're
watching, but also on study
coding.org, which is my channel
where I create applications. My
name is shad Sluiter, and I
welcome you to come to class
with me virtually even where you
can become a professional
software developer. So this
course that we're covering right
now is focusing on databases.
But as you can see from the
selections on steady coding.org,
that you can learn C sharp
programming for websites or Java
or Node js, and JavaScript and
other languages. So many of my
students have become
professional software developers
and have great jobs. And I'd
like the same thing to happen
for you. So come along, and join
us in class and plan your
future. So just as a reminder,
where we're going with this
application, this is the final
product. And as you can see, we
have a list of albums at the top
of the page. And then we have a
list of music or tracks at the
bottom, and then a YouTube
player so that we can hear the
music. So in the past video, we
created the database that goes
behind this top control, which
is a grid. And we're going to
work on some queries this video
where we can select items based
on what's in the database. So
searching for specific titles,
selecting specific columns of
this table. And then eventually,
we're going to come and create
this application that you see
and display the data on the
front end you might call it or
on the form of the application.
So let's go take a look at where
we were. And then we're going to
get closer to the vision that
you see here on the screen. So
as a reminder, we built our
application using this tool here
MAMP, which includes MySQL as
its database. So I've got the
two little green dots here
indicating that the application
is running and the database is
being served. Now I'm going to
click this button here that says
open start page. So here is the
start page. As you can see, the
address is localhost MAMP. I'm
going to the tools menu and
choosing my admin. And I'm going
to take a look at the database
here. So music two is what we
created in the last video. And
so far we have an albums item so
you can see on the screen now
that I have several items that I
imported in the last video so I
have a bunch of albums from The
Beatles. So I have the title,
the artists the year the image
name and the description, both
of those items at the end.
were taken directly from
Wikipedia. So in this video,
we're going to practice doing
some selections. And then in the
next we're going to do some
programming actually in the
form. So let's go to the part
that says SQL. And we're going
to learn how some SQL queries
work. So as you can see, there
is automatically some code
written for us, which is very
helpful. Let me zoom in a little
bit, so we can see very well on
the video. There we go. So
select star, it says from albums
were one. So let's make this
even simpler, I'm going to take
out the where collection, and
just say this statement, select
star from albums. And let's
click go and see what that does.
So what this is telling us is
select everything that there is
in the albums table. And you can
see that the list here includes
all of the items. Now we're
going to do a little bit more
sophisticated searches than
that. So let's focus in on this
last part where it says where so
where is going to be a
condition. So we can say, some
name, like ID, and then I'm
going to put in an equal sign,
and then specify a specific
number. So let's try three. So I
just happen to remember that the
first album in my table is ID
three. So if I click on go,
we're going to see exactly one
result, because album, three
here is Abbey Road. So let's try
a different search. So I'm going
to say where ID equals something
else. So I'm going to put in 17.
I believe 17 is one of my
albums. So let's click go. And
sure enough, it looks like Hard
Day's Night in my collection is
number 17. So that is one way to
do a SQL statement. Now let's do
another word, we can have a
condition to say something like
I want to look for where ID is
anything greater than 10. And
let's choose a go. And this
time, you can see that I have
two items, I have 16 and 17,
which are bigger than 10. You
can experiment with others,
let's try something like a less
than sign. So let's say if I say
ID is less than 10. And what
comes out now, so we've got
ourselves, four of them. So
34567 Are the results here. So
you can see that the SQL
statements are able to select
items based on a condition. All
right, so now we're going to do
another query. And this time,
I'm going to search in the title
of the album. So let's see if we
can find anything that has the
letter A in the album title. So
this will hopefully find things
like Abbey Road. So the way we
do this is we put in the word
album title after the word where
so where album title. Now
instead of an equal sign, I'm
using a like operator. So like
says we're going to match a
partial match. And so I want to
match something that is like the
letter A. Let's see if this does
anything. Now before I click the
Go button, I'm going to make
sure that this box down here
called retain query box has a
checkmark that will allow me to
come back and modify this
without retyping the entire
mess. So let's go ahead and
choose go. And I am
disappointed. The results down
below says it returned an empty
set. So nothing like a. So what
is missing here is the ability
to search for wildcards. So I'm
going to put in a percent sign
before the a and a percent sign
for the after, which means find
a somewhere in the middle of the
word. Let's see if that does any
better. So I click go. So let's
look at the results down below.
And you can see that there are
three results. It says here,
Abbey Road, Yellow Submarine and
Hard Day's Night are all
matched. And so this here is a
like statement that gives us a
result. So the percent sign and
the Like operator are both
important. Now a couple other
things that we're going to
notice here is these backticks.
So how do you type those if
you're working in here
application, because we're going
to be copying and pasting these
search queries into our Visual
Studio application. These are
actually optional. So I'm going
to delete the backticks they're
only useful is if you need them
for holding a space in your in
your query. So if I click go,
the query works just like it did
before. If I had something like
album collection as my name for
the table, I would have to put
in those backticks as you see it
here. But for right now, we
don't need them. So I'm just
going to back out to where I was
before.
Alright, let's do another go
just to make sure that it's
still working. Okay, so I have
three albums. Now, what if I
only care about retrieving a
certain pieces of these data? So
for instance, if I wanted to
know the album title, and I
cared about the year, just those
two, for some reason, that's
what my application needed. So
instead of the star, I would
erase that and change it to
something else. So if I type in
something like an A, you're
going to see that there are
suggestions here so album title
is what I want to select
I'm going to put a comma, and
what was the other I wanted to
year. So I'm going to put in the
word year. And those two column
names show up from the results
down here. Let's see if that
works. And I choose go. And the
results now indicate that I'm
only getting two columns in my
response. So if I'm ignoring
everything else in my database,
I can do specific searches using
the column names. Let's say I
want to rename the search
results. For some reason I can
say album title as the word
title. And year as let's make it
up about date of publish. You
can use any name you want,
really, let's choose go. And
let's see what that does at the
bottom. So now you can see that
the titles of the results now
are renamed. So title and date
of publish are the exact same
column names, it's just that
I've renamed them. That is
something that people do
frequently when they have to,
for some reason, match up a
property in their application to
a column name in a database. And
so here's a couple of examples
that we've done. So let me
summarize what I'll do on the
screen here of all of the
queries that you just wrote. So
first of all, we did just a
standard query where we selected
everything, then we did a query
where there is a greater than or
less than sign, then we did a
query with likes, and we
indicated that we had to have
wildcard characters before and
after a string. If we want to
get accurate results for the
likes. Then we wanted to be able
to select certain column names.
And so the column names are
specified instead of the star.
So star gives you all columns in
a table. And you can specify
just a few columns if you need
to, and ignore the rest. And
then finally, we have some
searches where we rename the
column results where we say,
rename the title as title, and
the year as date of publish. So
those are some of the things
that you can do with SQL. Now
there's a lot more things to do
with the SQL searches, but I
will leave those for another
exercise. In the meantime, we're
anxious to get this thing
working in our application. So
in the next video, we're going
to create an app that will
display the search results that
we've done here, and put them on
a form in a Windows app. So
let's get started with building
that app. Next. If you would
like to look at the full series
of this thing, you can either
subscribe to the channel that
you're looking at now on
YouTube, or you can see the more
extensive version on steady
coding.org, which is another
website.
Hi, and this second video of a
series, we're going to continue
to explore building a SQL
database application. Here's the
index of all of the things we're
going to learn. In the first
video, we work through creating
our first database. In this
video, we're going to start to
write some queries using the SQL
language. In the future, we're
going to talk about the front
end, connecting our database to
that front end, doing some
searches inserting records,
creating foreign keys, joining
tables together, creating what's
called UML diagrams, making
compound queries or multiple
queries in one step, we're going
to delete items from the
database. And then finally, at
the very end of this course,
we're talking about features
that we didn't get to, but you
could probably explore. So this
whole series here is available,
not only here where you're
watching, but also on study
coding.org, which is my channel
where I create applications. My
name is shad Sluiter, and I
welcome you to come to class
with me virtually even where you
can become a professional
software developer. So this
course that we're covering right
now is focusing on databases.
But as you can see from the
selections on steady coding.org,
that you can learn C sharp
programming for websites or Java
or no JS, JavaScript and other
languages. So many of my
students have become
professional software developers
and have great jobs. And I'd
like the same thing to happen
for you. So come along, and join
us in class and plan your
future. So just as a reminder,
where we're going with this
application, this is the final
product. And as you can see, we
have a list of albums at the top
of the page. And then we have a
list of music or tracks at the
bottom, and then a YouTube
player so that we can hear the
music. So in the past video, we
created the database that goes
behind this top control, which
is a grid. And we're going to
work on some queries this video
where we can select items based
on what's in the database. So
searching for specific titles,
selecting specific columns of
this table, and then eventually
we're going to come and create
this application that you see
and display the data on the
front end you might call it or
on
In the form of the application,
so let's go take a look at where
we were. And then we're going to
get closer to the vision that
you see here on the screen. So
as a reminder, we built our
application using this tool here
MAMP, which includes MySQL as
its database. So I've got the
two little green dots here
indicating that the application
is running and the database is
being served. Now, I'm going to
click this button here that says
open start page. So here's the
start page. As you can see, the
address is localhost MAMP. I'm
going to the tools menu and
choosing my admin. And I'm going
to take a look at the database
here. So music two is what we
created in the last video. And
so far, we have an albums item.
So you can see on the screen now
that I have several items that I
imported in the last video, so I
have a bunch of albums from The
Beatles. So I have the title,
the artists, the year, the image
name and the description, both
of those items at the end are
taken directly from Wikipedia.
So in this video, we're going to
practice doing some selections.
And then in the next we're going
to do some programming actually
in the form. So let's go to the
part that says SQL. And we're
going to learn how some SQL
queries work. So as you can see,
there is automatically some code
written for us, which is very
helpful. Let me zoom in a little
bit. So we can see very well on
the video. There we go. So
select star, it says from albums
were one. So let's make this
even simpler, I'm going to take
out the where collection, and
just say this statement, select
star from albums. And let's
click go and see what that does.
So what this is telling us is
select everything that there is
in the albums table. And you can
see that the list here includes
all of the items. Now we're
going to do a little bit more
sophisticated searches than
that. So let's focus in on this
last part where it says where so
where is going to be a
condition. So we can say some
name like ID, and then I'm going
to put in an equal sign and then
specify a specific number. So
let's try three. So I just
happen to remember that the
first album in my table is ID
three. So if I click on go,
we're going to see exactly one
result, because album three here
is Abbey Road. So let's try a
different search. So I'm going
to say where ID equals something
else. So I'm going to put in 17.
I believe 17 is one of my
albums. So let's click go. And
sure enough, it looks like Hard
Day's Night in my collection is
number 17. So that is one way to
do a SQL statement. Now let's do
another word, we can have a
condition to say something like
I'm going to look for where ID
is anything greater than 10. And
let's choose a go. And this
time, you can see that I have
two items, I have 16 and 17,
which are bigger than 10. You
can experiment with others,
let's try something like a less
than sign. So let's say if I say
ID is less than 10. And what
comes out now, so we've got
ourselves four of them. So 34567
Are the results here. So you can
see that the SQL statements are
able to select items based on a
condition. All right, so now
we're going to do another query.
And this time, I'm going to
search in the title of the
album. So let's see if we can
find anything that has the
letter A in the album title. So
this will hopefully find things
like Abbey Road. So the way we
do this is we put in the word
album title after the word where
so where album title. Now
instead of an equal sign, I'm
using a like operator. So like
says we're going to match a
partial match. And so I want to
match something that is like the
letter A. Let's see if this does
anything. Now before I click the
Go button, I'm going to make
sure that this box down here
called retain query box has a
checkmark that will allow me to
come back and modify this
without retyping the entire
mess. So let's go ahead and
choose go and I am disappointed.
The results down below says it
returned an empty set. So
nothing like a. So what is
missing here is the ability to
search for wildcards. So I'm
going to put in a percent sign
before the a and a percent sign
for the after, which means find
a somewhere in the middle of the
word. Let's see if that does any
better. So I click go. So let's
look at the results down below.
And you can see that there are
three results. It says here
Abbey Road, Yellow Submarine and
Hard Day's Night are all
matched. And so this here is a
like statement that gives us a
result. So the percent sign and
the Like operator are both
important. Now a couple other
things that we're going to
notice here is these backticks.
So how do you type those if
you're working in here
application because we're going
to be copying and pasting these
search queries into our Visual
Studio application. These are
actually optional, so I'm going
to delete the backticks they're
only used
sequel is if you need them for
holding a space in your in your
query. So if I click go, the
query works just like it did
before. If I had something like
album collection as my name for
the table, I would have to put
in those backticks as you see it
here. But for right now, we
don't need them. So I'm just
going to back out to where I was
before.
All right, let's do another go
just to make sure that it's
still working. Okay, so I have
three albums. Now, what if I
only care about retrieving a
certain pieces of these data. So
for instance, if I wanted to
know the album title, and I
cared about the year, just those
two, for some reason, that's
what my application needed. So
instead of the star, I would
erase that and change it to
something else. So if I type in
something like an A, you're
going to see that there are
suggestions here. So album title
is what I want to select, I'm
going to put a comma, and what
was the other I wanted a year.
So I'm going to put in the word
year. And those two column names
show up from the results down
here. Let's see if that works.
And I choose go. And the results
now indicate that I'm only
getting two columns in my
response. So if I'm ignoring
everything else in my database,
I can do specific searches,
using the column names. Let's
say I want to rename the search
results. For some reason I can
say album title as the word
title. And year as let's make it
up, how about date of publish,
you can use any name you want,
really, let's choose go. And
let's see what that does at the
bottom. So now you can see that
the titles of the results now
are renamed. So title and date
of publish are the exact same
column names, it's just that
I've renamed them. That is
something that people do
frequently when they have to,
for some reason, match up a
property in their application to
a column name in a database. And
so here's a couple of examples
that we've done. So let me
summarize what I'll do on the
screen here of all of the
queries that you just wrote. So
first of all, we did just a
standard query where we selected
everything, then we did a query
where there is a greater than or
less than sign, then we did a
query with likes, and we
indicated that we had to have
wildcard characters before and
after a string. If we want to
get accurate results for the
likes. Then we wanted to be able
to select certain column names.
And so the column names are
specified instead of the star.
So star gives you all columns in
a table. And you can specify
just a few columns if you need
to, and ignore the rest. And
then finally, we have some
searches where we rename the
column results where we say,
rename the title as title, and
the year as date of publish. So
those are some of the things
that you can do with SQL. Now
there's a lot more things to do
with the SQL searches, but I
will leave those for another
exercise. In the meantime, we're
anxious to get this thing
working in our application. So
in the next video, we're going
to create an app that will
display the search results that
we've done here, and put them on
a form in a Windows app. So
let's get started with building
that app. Next, if you would
like to look at the full series
of this thing, you can either
subscribe to the channel that
you're looking at now on
YouTube, or you can see the more
extensive version on steady
coding.org, which is another
website.
Hi, and welcome to another video
in this project here with our
SQL database application. In
this index, we're showing all of
the things that we're doing in
this course, in the first two
videos, we created a database,
and then we ran some queries. In
this video, we're going to
create the front end. So we're
going to actually start creating
an application in Visual Studio,
that will be able to display the
results of any queries that we
do against our database. In the
future, we're going to have
these topics after we finish all
of that they'll still be more
left unsaid. So there'll be
future plans that you can
implement. So my name is shad
slaughter, and I teach software
development at Grand Canyon
University in Phoenix, Arizona.
And so I'm glad that you're
here, you're going to become a
professional software developer
if you're able to do these kinds
of tasks. So my website is study
coding.org, where you'll find
all of the courses that I've
taught over the past years. So
not only with web development
and databases, but with mobile
applications and security and
other issues. So check it out.
And if you'd like anything
there, you can join for a small
fee, and you get the source
code. So let's take a peek at
the application as it is in its
finished state. So you can see
that we have tables that are
being searched and then we're
playing some music. So these are
all albums that are from the
Beatles and then tracks on
Each of those albums and then a
player here, so we can see a
YouTube video. Now what we're
going to do and this video is
we're going to focus in on this
section up here where we're able
to display the albums and do
searches against them. So in the
previous video, we set up the
database. Now we're going to
create the application that does
the front end. Alright, so now
let's talk about the different
ways that people use
applications when they are
talking to databases. The app
that we're going to build here
is a very simple app. And that's
why I chose this desktop app to
do it, it doesn't take much
effort to learn how to do this
front end. However, if you want
to become a professional
software developer, you should
probably learn how to create web
applications. Now I have
tutorials for how to do that in
different languages. So C sharp
is a very popular choice for
creating web apps. And so the
key word that you're looking for
is asp.net. And that is the
framework that Microsoft uses to
connect websites to databases
and create a fully functional
web page that is an application.
An even more popular way to
create websites with a common
language is Java. So Spring Boot
is the key word that you should
be looking for when you're
looking for frameworks on how to
build websites with Java. And of
course, I have a tutorial for
how to build a java web
application. Another very
popular choice for building
websites is using the language
php. And as a matter of fact,
the application that you see in
this tutorial is MAMP, which
includes PHP as its default
language interpreter. And so PHP
is also available on steady
coding.org. If you want to learn
how to build websites with that
language. Also, you can work
with pure JavaScript, if you
work with the Express framework
on Node js, you can build a
website in the same manner that
other websites are built in
other frameworks. So there's
lots of different choices that
you can pick from to build a
website. Why are we then not
building a website, you might
ask, because this class is
focused in on SQL and the
databases that go with it. So
it's very simple to build the
application that we're about to
right now. But if you want to be
more advanced, if you want to be
more employable, then you should
probably take some of the other
courses that I offer, or others
do, on how to build websites and
connect them to databases like
MySQL. Anyway, we're trying to
build this app. So what we have
on the screen is our final
product, and we're going to
implement just the first part
here. And let's get started. So
as you can see, I have the
database still running in the
background here. So I actually
don't need that right now. So
I'm going to just push that off
on to my other desktop. Okay, so
let's get started with Visual
Studio, you can see that I have
two versions installed on my
computer, I have 2022 and 2019.
So honestly, 2019 works a little
bit faster on my old computer.
But since we're in 2022, we
might as well get with the times
and show you this bigger,
heavier version that is going to
have all the features we need.
So here it is. This is the
startup screen to say what kind
of projects would you like to
open or build. So I'm going to
select the item that says create
a new project. And I'm going to
make sure that I select the
right places. So the templates
up here you can search for or
you can filter them using these
choices. So I want to do C sharp
Windows app and a desktop, then
I'm going to go down and pick
one of these two options. Now,
Microsoft is really good at
confusing people about which one
is which, what is the difference
between a Windows Forms app and
a Windows Forms app with dotnet
framework? Well, in the in the
description, this one says it
uses dotnet framework, these two
things are different even though
they have very confusing and
similar language. So I believe
the choice that I made for this
one to get the most current is
the first item that says Windows
Form app. And dotnet framework
below is not the choice that is
for an older version. So let's
play try next and see what
happens. So now we need to
create this with some kind of a
name. So I'm going to say this
is a database SQL music app. And
I'm going to leave the other
choices the same you can see the
location where I'm putting this
is on my desktop. And let's
choose Next. Now I know that
I've chosen the correct
application type because of the
next screen. So the framework
that pops up next is VS version
6.0 of dotnet. So it says long
term support. So at the time of
this video here in 2022. This is
the most current version that I
can add program. If you pick
something that's older than
this, frankly, it will work just
just as well probably. But six
Dotto is what we've got right
now. And if you're from the
future, this will probably still
continue to work very similar.
So I'm not doing anything that
is cutting edge with the dotnet
framework. So I'm picking the
current one just because that's
a good practice. OK, let's
create it and then give it a
minute to build everything. All
right, everything came out. So
we have form one here. And I'm
just going to click the green
button at the top that says make
this application run
I just want to test it out to
make sure everything's good. And
I should see an app on the
screen. So sure enough, here
comes form one. And I could
Minimize Visual Studio in the
background. So that way, I have
my beautiful blank app to look
at on the beautiful background.
Now I'm going to put two things
on this screen to get started
with. And then we're going to
start connecting our application
to the database. So the two
things that I'm going to put on
here, our button, and then some
kind of a data grid that I can
use to display a bunch of pieces
of data. So the button we're
going to drag in from our common
controls area. And I'm going to
change the text of the button so
that it says load albums. So at
least the user knows what that
button is supposed to do. Let's
make it a little bit wider, so
it all fits. And the second item
that I'm looking for is in the
data controls area. So I
searched for something called
the data grid view. And the data
grid view is really why we're
building this app in Windows
Forms because it requires no
configuration, almost none
anyway, so it'll be able to
display data from the database.
And of course, I need to make
this wider, I've got kind of a
poor user interface design. When
we're finished here, we're going
to have a whole bunch of stuff
on one screen, which is very
easy to program. But really, if
I were teaching this as a user
interface class and a user
experience, I would have
multiple forms. But remember,
the focus on this course is on
SQL and how to make the database
work. So that's why our app is
going to look kind of busy on
the on the main form. So I got
this thing here with it with a
form and it has a button and a
grid control. Next, I'm going to
have an album class. So this is
a data class in object oriented
programming that will connect
our properties in the in the in
the class with the column names
in our database table. Now I'm
recalling all of the things that
I put into the database. As I
create this album class, each
property here is going to
represent a string or an integer
or something like that, some
data type that is in an album.
So the first thing that each
album has is an ID number. So I
type in PR O P, and then press
TAB TAB to get the property of
an integer. The first thing is
called ID. The second property
is the album's name. So you
could call it album title, you
can call it album name, I'm
going to purposely not name this
the same thing as my database.
Because I want to make sure that
we we, we handle certain
exceptions or certain cases,
when there's discrepancies
between a class name and a table
name. Generally, people like to
keep them the same, but I'm
purposely making them different
here, just to highlight some
things. Then we go on, we're
going to have the artists name.
So in my case, it's always the
Beatles. And then the next one
is a year. So an integer value
for the year comes up, we're
going to make an image URL. So
this is the title image of the
album. So this is not the URL
for the song The the YouTube
song yet, this is just an image
of what we got a Wikipedia and
also from Wikipedia, we grabbed
the first paragraph, which is
the description. So that also
matches as a string type. So
I've got a bunch of properties
here that are corresponding to
the table that we made in the
previous video, all of these
things about an album. Now I
know that later, I'm going to
add some songs to the album. But
I want to keep this simple for
this video. So I'm just going to
leave comments now to say that
coming soon, is a list of type
track. And this list of tracks
will be associated with the
album. But right now, we're just
going to put it in comments
because we're doing one thing at
a time. Okay, so we got
ourselves a bunch of properties.
Now I'm going to make some data
and put it into our form. And
we'll connect to the database in
a while. But for right now, I
just want to create some dummy
data that will make sure that
this grid has something to look
at. Now I want to handle all of
the database operations in
another class. And it will be
the kind of the interface
between the app and the table.
So I'm going to call this thing
albums. Dao. So Dao is a
shortcut for data access object,
its job is to be able to do all
the queries. And then it'll
provide a layer between these,
the front end and the back end.
So just to make sure that we
keep these things, kind of
simple. In each video, I'm going
to first of all construct this
thing without connecting to the
database itself. I'm going to
create some dummy data, and then
we'll display it in the grid. So
we're not going to keep this
code here for very long. It's
just a test. I'm going to type
the word list and an open
bracket. And one of the nice
features that you get of Visual
Studio 2022 is the type of head
help and it predicted correctly
that I wanted to make a list
called albums. It's a list of
type album. What it did not
predict was that I wanted to
initialize the list so it has
some list value in it. There's
not an end
D list, it's not a no list, it's
got. It's got values. So it's a,
it's a list of zero values, but
it still is defined. Alright, so
this is just a placeholder right
now we're just going to create
an empty list. Now let's go into
form one. And let's create some
events that will fill this list
with some fake data. So I'm
going to switch over to form one
design. And I'm going to double
click on the load albums. And so
now we have an event for this
button, click so button, click
one.
Now, this is going to be
temporary code. We'll delete it
in a few minutes, but we're just
going to test it out. So I'm
going to add the albums Dao
class and initialize it with a
new instance of this class. So
when we click the button, it'll
create a brand new list from
scratch every time we click it.
Now, as soon as I have the list
created, I'm going to start
filling it with some data. So
let's create a new album. I'll
name this thing as an album of a
one. And after we create the new
album, let's fill it with some
properties. So the first item
that we're up to is ID. So Id
one sounds good to me, let's
take the album name to be my
first album. And I might also be
the artist. So put my own name
in there, the year is 2022.
Let's put in an image URL of
nothing yet, I guess I don't
know what URL I want for the
picture.
For the description, let's put
in nothing special. So now we
have a one. And we might also
make this have two albums since
it is a list. So I'll copy and
paste album one, and I'll name
the second one is a two and
change the first name. So it is
my second album.
Now what I'd like to do is add
the first song to my albums Dao.
So I'm going to try that, but
I'm going to come up with a
problem. So it says, albums Dao
dot albums. Now there's a list
of albums in there, but I can't
see it for some reason. But it
allows me to continue ahead
typing and add a one. So why
can't I actually add something
that album's a one, let's see,
it says in my problem help, it
says it's inaccessible due to
its protection level. So means I
probably made it private. And I
could turn it public so that I
could actually do the thing that
I'm trying to do now. So let's
go back to the album's Dao. And
sure enough, let's go here and
change this to public. And we'll
save it.
And now what happens when I come
back to my form one, so the
error goes away, looks like that
was the problem. And we've
solved it.
Now very helpful, I go to the
next line, and I type in an A,
and I get some type of head
help. And it guesses that I want
to add the second album to the
list. Okay, great. So all of
that work was to simply add two
albums to our list of data. Now,
I want to associate this list
with the control that's on the
screen. Now one of the tricky
parts about building an
application with C sharp and
Windows Forms is called a
binding source. So binding
source is the ability to connect
a list of items such as albums,
to the control, so the grid
control. And so I'm just going
to define this here. And you're
going to kind of follow along to
see how the format works. So
binding source is the class name
that is allowed to connect these
two. And I'm going to let the
type ahead helped me to call it
a new binding source. Now I'm
going to rename the binding
source because I'm going to
specifically have one for the
album's and another one later
for the tracks. So I'm going to
name this one as the album
binding source. So to make that
work, or make that binding
source work, we're going down to
the click button action. And so
after I've added a couple of
albums, I'm going to create a
connection between the lists and
the grid view. So this is where
the binding source comes in. So
I'm going to define this thing
as the album binding source dot
and get a property called data
source. And I'm going to set
that equal to be the list that I
made. So it is the album's Dao.
And it's not as smart as I
thought, I have to add a dot and
tell it that the list is called
albums. So putting these two
together should allow the grid
source to show these two new
albums. Now there's one more
final step that we have to do,
we have to tell the grid view
that this binding source is
associated with it. So I type in
group data grid view, one dot,
and it has a property called
datasource. And so
programmatically, we're setting
it up to be equal to this list.
Okay, so now all of this
connection should be done
correctly. At least I think it
is. Let's try it. I'm going to
run the app. So I click the
little green triangle at the
top. And let's see what happens.
So I've got the app. Let's see,
I'll minimize the rest of this.
So it's kind of out of the way.
And what is Cortana get out of
the way. Okay, so here we go.
Now I'm going to choose Load
albums, and look at there. So
the binding source of these two
albums now displays all of the
squares in like a spreadsheet
grid. So that's the magic of
this control. It automatically
creates the number of columns it
needs, and if these get
To be too long, it allows it
puts in scroll bars. And so this
is easier to do than if you're
trying to create some kind of a
web page. Most of this binding
source and data source does the
work for you. All right. So that
is not exactly what we want. We
have a couple of albums, they're
nice albums, but they're not the
real ones. What I want to do is
get all those Beatles albums
that are in the database. And so
we have still not connected our
database to the control.
Although you can see we are
almost there. So in the next
video, we're going to do that
we're going to set up a
connection between the SQL
Server and the app that you see
here. And then we'll get the
data live from the database. So
let's take a look at the index
of where we've been. So you can
see that we're on part three,
which is building a front end.
So the front end is got some
pieces to it, it's not complete,
but at least we can see where
we're going. What's next. Next
is to connect that app that we
just started and connect it to
the database. So we're not using
fake data anymore. We're getting
the actual albums from The
Beatles. And so that will be the
next task that we do. So we're
on Part Four coming up.
Hi, welcome back to another SQL
application tutorial. So we're
in an application series, which
is about building applications
using MySQL. We did Part Three
already. And now we're moving on
to part four. So in the previous
videos, we've created some
tables. And now we're about
ready to connect those databases
to the front end of our
application. So the other parts
that are coming up are going to
help us do searches and to make
more complex queries. And
eventually, we're going to get
to the point where we have a
fully functioning app. So if
this is interesting to you, then
let's keep right on going. My
name is shad Sluiter, and I
teach software development and
computer science at Grand Canyon
University. So many of my
students are using these
tutorials to become professional
software developers. So
congratulations on choosing a
good path for a good job, I hope
you have a great future. Now
here is the application where we
left it from the last video
where we had a simple set of
fake data, we had two albums in
our data access object. And they
really don't relate to the
database yet, however, they look
like the albums that we put into
the database. So we're getting
closer. So by the time you're
done here, you're going to see
the application show all of the
Beatles albums on the screen
instead of these two fakie.
Alright, so let's go modify this
data access object and make it
work like it's supposed to. So
we're going to delete all the
junk that was already in our
Dao, and we're going to add some
new things. So in this first
step, we have to make a
connection to our database. So
every database has a user name
and password authentication or
some kind of a way to make sure
that the right people are
looking at the database. And so
ours is going to be very simple
to start with. The first
property that we put in is
called the data source. So the
data source is where does the
server live. Now if we were on
the internet, we would put in
some kind of an IP address, or
we would put in Amazon aws.com,
or some detailed long name for a
server. Since local host is
here, that means we're talking
to the MAMP server. So remember,
we have this map server running
here. And this thing is running
on localhost. So we're, we're
essentially doubling up our
computer to do two things. One
is the application, and the
other is the database server. In
the real life. Sometimes these
are divided into separate
machines. But anyway, we're
using localhost for now. Next,
we need to specify something
called a port. So let's bring in
the map server again and check
out to see where this might be.
So let's go to MAMP. And choose
Preferences. And let's see what
else we can do. It says a bunch
of stuff about PHP, what I'm
interested in is ports. So in
this tab, here, we can see that
there are ports. So 80 is
currently the the setting for my
web server. And then 3306 is the
port for our SQL database. So
ports are just numbers that
computers agree to communicate
on like it's like a channel.
It's like on your TV when you
have channel 15.1 and 15.2. It's
like they're the dot part is the
sub channel or it's the port
number for a major channel. So
our port number here is 3306.
Now we need to specify how to
log in to this server. So user
name and password is what we
need to provide. Now I know that
the username and password for my
particular MAMP installation is
root and the password is root.
If you're using USB web server
or wham you might have something
slightly different so check the
help files or the installation
guide. If this does
and work for you. So root and
root works for MAMP. The last
item on the list is telling it
which database it needs to
connect to. And as you might
recall, the name is music two.
So just bringing up music two is
right here, just refreshing our
memory of what we have for data.
Now, the way a data access
object works is you create a
bunch of methods that are going
to perform actions for the main
program. So the first action
that I'm going to create is one
that will get all of the albums
from the database. So the return
type of this function is called
a list of type album. And then
appropriate name for this would
be Git or fetch or search for
all. So I'm going to name it as
get all albums, because I think
that's the most clear. Now to
make this work, I'm going to
start by creating an empty list
of albums. And then I'm going to
return that list at the end of
the function. So I'm going to
rename the list as return these.
So the next step is we're going
to create a connection. So I'm
going to type in something that
will not work at the first it's
called My SQL connection. And
it's a new class. So I will
create a new class and one
parameter in it is the
connection string. Now, why
doesn't it work? Well, by
default, Microsoft expects you
to be talking to a SQL Server,
that's their version of SQL. But
we built this thing with MySQL,
so we have to go get a extra
piece of software called the
dependency to make this work. So
let's see if the computer is
able to help us out in our
problem. So I'm going to hover
here, and it says, I have no
idea what you're talking about
my SQL connection doesn't exist
in my list of known classes.
Let's see if there are potential
fixes. So the first few fixes
are, you can generate this and
create your own. However, you
can see that there is a MySQL
dot data or data, different
dependency. So let's go ahead
and choose this. And it says I'm
going to install this. So how is
it going to do that, let's go
ahead and choose Find the latest
version and install it. Now I'm
going to just sit and watch and
magically, something will
happen. And the problem
disappeared. Where did the
problem get resolved? Let's take
a look at how that is resolved.
So you can see that the error is
gone. What I'm going to do is
right click on the project, go
down to New get packages. So
manage nougat packages, is the
dependency manager in SQL. And
you can see that it says here
I'm looking at installed
packages. And my sequel, that
data is already been installed.
And it comes from the Oracle
Corporation. Now, Oracle
actually owns MySQL, they paid
quite a bit of money for it. And
I guess owning free software is
maybe a status symbol, do they
actually make any money on
MySQL, they must somehow I'm not
quite sure how they do it. But
anyway, they are the owners of
MySQL, and they manage this
extra dependency that allows us
to connect using their classes
here. So apparently, it's
working, I'm going to close the
nougat Package Manager. Now the
next step that we're going to do
is we're going to create an open
connection. So I'm going to type
in my connection and type dot
open. And that will log in to
the server. Now there's going to
be a whole bunch of more stuff
coming up here, we're going to
do a SQL statement, and then
we're going to execute it. But I
want to first check to make sure
that everything is connecting
properly. So I'm going to skip
some lines and then just type
return, and then the list called
return these. So right now it's
still an empty list, but it will
not be an empty list for very
long. Now I want to make sure
that I can test this out. So I'm
going back to form one in the
code here. And I'm going to
start removing all of the junk
that we put in earlier. So I'm
going to delete the majority of
the junk that we put in earlier
and just leave this binding
source as the item. So I'm going
to create a new instance of the
album's data access object. So
we'll do albums Dao equals a new
albums Dao. Now, I want to
associate the datasource of this
grid with the event called get
all albums. So I'm going to just
erase the one piece of code here
at the end of the write and
change it to get all albums. Now
remember, get all Elbaz is still
returning an empty list, but it
will try to connect to the
server let's let's just run this
and see if there are any errors.
Okay, the application is up and
running. Let's go ahead and
choose get all albums. And it
returned an empty list you can
see it must have curl must have
connected correctly. Let's let's
try to break that and see if
there's a problem that we can
resolve later. So I'm going to
go in and change something. So
local host I could change any
one of these details so
localhost exe, or I could put in
the wrong port number or I could
put in the wrong username. Any
one of those will cause this to
break. So I'm going to put an X
in for the server name and then
try it again.
So now when I choose Load I
albums, what happens?
There, I finally get an error,
something's coming up here and
what is it?
It says no such host is known.
So you may have gotten a
different error based on whether
you change the password or the
port number. But this is telling
me that the open connection did
not work. And so the program
stopped. So that's one way to
test to see if you got the right
connection string or not. All
right, let's fix that. So I want
it to actually work. Now we're
going to finish off with this
get all albums. So the next item
down is we're going to write the
SQL statement. So I'm going to
create a new, a new instance of
an object called a my SQL
command. So I'll name it is
command. The values that we're
going to create when we do the
instantiation is two parts.
First is the string, which is
the actual SQL statement. So
we're going to say select star
from the albums table. And then
we have to provide a comma and
then the connection that we
defined earlier. Next, we're
going to use a USING statement.
So there's USING statement, it's
kind of like a while loop, it
says use this object, and then
when it's done with a loop, then
destroy the object. So what I
want to do is create something
called a MySQL data reader. And
this reader will be the result
of executing the command that we
defined up on line 25. So this
reader then can be used in a
loop to be able to fetch each
line. Now we're going to go
through each column in the data
table. And we're going to
associate it with a new property
in a class. So we're going to
make a new album, I'll name it
A. And for each of the
properties, we're going to go
through the column names. So ID
is going to be equal to the
reader dot get, and we want to
get the right type of value. So
this is going to be an integer.
So integer, 32 is the size of
the data, you could use other
integer types like 16. But 32
seems to work. So we're gonna
say at position zero, expect to
see an integer. The next item is
the album name or the title. So
that is coming from reader dot
get string at the second column,
which is item number one. And
then so on, we go down to the
artists name, and the year and
the image URL. And then finally,
the description. Notice that the
index number goes from 01234,
and five, so there are five
numbers for six columns of data.
And we have to match up the data
type accordingly, otherwise, the
program won't work. After we
have the new album, called a we
want to add it to our list. So
return these dot add is the
command that will attach this as
another item in our search
results. Now to clean up after
ourselves, we want to close the
connection. So SQL might be
smart enough to close the
connection for us. But it's
always supposed to be here. So
after you're done query, do
connection dot close. So this
time, we should be able to run
the app. And instead of getting
just empty data, we might see
something. Let's go ahead and
try it out. Okay, the app is up
and running. Let's see what
happens when I choose Get load
albums. Okay, and there they
are. So I got lucky and
everything worked out fine. Now
I'm going to create an error
just to see if we can do some
troubleshooting. So let's close
this. And let's say I changed
one of these things, instead of
a five, I put a six. What would
that do? What kind of an error
Do you suppose that would make?
It probably won't work. But
let's see why. Let's go ahead
and choose run this. And now it
says here you have specified an
invalid column ordinal. So in
other words, I only had up to
five and you chose six. So that
one here is I suppose that's an
English. Sometimes computer
errors are hard to understand.
Let's say instead of get int i
accidentally put in get string.
So let's see what get string
will do for us what kind of an
error will that too. So get
string is not it's not given to
let me It says an ID is not a
string. Here's a really common
thing. So let's say I make a
mistake in my SQL statement. So
instead of albums, I put in the
word album, and let's see if
that makes a difference. Let's
run that.
So now I got the application
running and I choose go. And we
got an issue. It says here an
exception it says table music to
dot album doesn't exist. So if
you do a typo in this statement
right here, things aren't going
to go well either. So albums is
the name. Another good practice
in writing SQL statements is not
to rely on the star for
selecting all items from the
table. This will make your code
more rigid, you might say or
more, more specific, but it will
also avoid ever so if I change
the star to ID album, artists
and year and all the rest of
them, it should still work the
same if I've typed those
correctly, so I'm going to try
it again. Run the app and when I
choose Get albums, I've got a
problem. It says here the
problem is that there is no such
thing as image you
URL, what is the image URL
supposed to be? So let's bring
that up. Here it is. Image Name.
Okay. So that's what it is.
Let's fix that. Okay, so image
name should work. Let's try to
run it again and see what
happens this time.
Okay, here we go load albums.
And this time, they all seem to
work like they're supposed to.
So we've got ourselves a working
SELECT statement, we've got the
first section done of our
application. Now, it would be
kind of nice to be able to
search like, right now I'm
getting all of the albums, how
do I do a search so that I can
only get some albums of the ones
that I'm interested in? Well,
that's exactly what we'll do. In
the next video, we'll do a
select statement using the where
clause, so that way, we can do
searches on our collection.
Hi, and welcome back to another
edition of our SQL application
tutorial. In this application,
we're demonstrating how to use
MySQL in various different
stages of app development. So
we're up to part five, which is
how to create searches. So if
you haven't caught the first
four parts, how to set up an
application, how to set up a
database and how to do some
queries, then go back in that
playlist and check those out.
Right now we're trying to create
a searchable text box where we
can put in a partial word, and
then get some search results
from a list of albums. So
there's a whole bunch more stuff
coming up. So look at all of
these subjects that will make a
complete app. And then of
course, when we get to the end,
I'll give you some challenges so
that you can continue on with
your learning. My name is shad
Sluiter, and I teach software
development at Grand Canyon
University in Phoenix, Arizona,
a lot of my students have become
professional software
developers, which I assume is
what you're trying to do here,
as well. So stick with me. And
you can also look at my website
at steady coding.org, where you
can become a software developer
with C sharp or Java, make
yourself mobile applications or
other things that are important
to the career of a software
developer. So I'm glad you're
here. Let's get started now with
doing searches so that our
application is more powerful
than it was before. So I'm
bringing up on the screen here,
everything that we've created,
and also a preview of where
we're going before the end of
this video. So first of all, you
notice we have MAMP, which is
our database server. And then we
have the Visual Studio
application that we have in
front of us. What's new in this
video is this box up here that
says Search. So if I were to put
a letter in like the letter A
and choose Search, you're going
to see that only albums in my
database that have the letter A
are given as a result. So you
can see Abbey Road, Yellow
Submarine and Hard Day's Night.
Let's try something else like M
y and see if there's anything
that has the word my in it
doesn't look like it. Let's try
another one. So let's try H E.
And you can probably guess that
help is one of the songs that
The Beatles wrote. If I leave
the search box empty and choose
Search, I should get all the
results. And the button here
that says load albums still
continues to work and shows all
of the albums in my database. So
that's what we're going to build
right now. Okay, so we've just
gone back in time for one video.
And I am now left with the state
of the application as it was
before where we had a load
albums button but no search box.
So let's start from this point,
and then move forward. So let's
start with the user interface.
And then we'll do the back end
programming in a minute. So the
user interface changes are
pretty simple, we're going to
put a button on here and put the
word search on it. And so that
way, we can at least have an
event. So let's put the text of
search on the top. And then
we'll also put a text box on the
screen. So a text box is where
we can enter in some values and
then use the contents of that
box to do the searching.
Alright, so that's all the
interface changes we're going to
make. Now let's start
programming. So I'm going to go
to the search button and double
click it. And we have a new
button click handler button to
click. Now for the first version
of this button, I'm just going
to steal all of the code from
button one, which was to search
for everything in the database.
So let's just copy and paste
this here. And then we'll make
some modifications so that way
it will search for only specific
songs. So the one important
change that we're going to make
here is changing the method that
we're going to rely on from our
data access object, our Dao, so
instead of searching for
everything, I'm going to rename
this method and provide it one
parameter, we're going to name
it as search titles, and then
provide the contents of that
textbox. So the contents of the
textbox are textbox one dot txt.
So those are the only changes we
need to make here in form one to
make it work. But we need to now
add this event here because you
can see that search titles has
an underlying read on it, which
means it doesn't exist yet and
we need to go fix that now. So
let's go open up albums D
AIO and let's go check to see
what we have here. So I'm going
to start selecting, we've got
this get all albums method. And
so I'm holding the shift key and
the arrow to select all the way
down to the very last. So this
is going to be duplicated and
then modified slightly. So I'm
pressing ctrl C. Alright, so now
I've got the items copied, I'm
going to create some space here,
and then Ctrl V for paste. Let's
see, if I got one extra bracket
it looks like so let's take out
him. So that little red thing
goes away. Okay, so now I've got
a duplicate of the method called
get all albums, what I want to
do is change that to search
titles. Inside of the method,
I'm going to put in a parameter
called string, and we'll name it
search term. So we're expecting
to get some information from the
form. So that way we can query
the database based on a keyword
search. Now let's save this and
go back to form one CS and see
if the error goes away. So sure
enough, now search titles with a
textbox. One text parameter is
now valid. So the two different
methods, two different methods
sync up well. So let's go back
to the DAO and continue working.
What I'm going to do first seems
like the logical thing to do,
but we will, we'll have errors,
but let's type it out anyway,
just see what the first
intentions would be, if I were
programming this without some
documentation to look at. So
what I want to do then is in the
sequel search string, I want to
add the WHERE statement. And I
want to say I want to search for
all albums where the album title
is like the search term. And so
will that work, if you remember
from previous videos, that we're
missing the percent sign, which
is a wildcard character. And so
that's the first problem that
will cause this to error out.
But there's another, but anyway,
I'm going to try and test it
anyway. So let's put in a search
term with a percent, and then a
percent to follow it. And let's
see if that works. I predicted
it won't. So let's just test it
and prove my point. So I'm
searching for the letter A, and
then type search. And sure
enough, it doesn't work. Look at
the error. It says you have
something wrong with your syntax
right near the word search term
at line one. And so now we're
baffled. We tried to do this
with other searches in the past.
But for some reason, our
application doesn't behave like
it did in the PHP myadmin
screen. So what are we going to
do, the first thing I'm going to
do is stitch together a couple
of things into a single string.
So I'm going to name my string
as search wild phrase, which is
simply the search term with an
addition of a percent sign at
the beginning and another at the
end. And so that's step one, to
make this whole string work a
little bit better. So now in my
brilliants, I think well, I can
just take that string now and
attach it to the SQL statement
that I had before. Will this
work? Let's try it and see if it
doesn't. So I run the
application. And I type in a
letter and choose Search. And
sure enough, we have the same
error. So I'm not getting any
closer. Well, I am. But I'm
trying to show you the common
errors that I went through as a
first time programmer. And what
you're probably trying to do as
well. So we're going to abandon
this idea and move toward the
solution. A further step toward
the solution is to get rid of
this trying to concatenate
strings together and use a
placeholder. So I'm going to put
an at symbol and search to make
this happen. So let's figure out
where I came up with that. So
actually, I looked in the
documentation, believe it or
not, and Microsoft tells us what
to do. What we're trying to
prevent is called SQL injection
attacks. And so this great
article is very simple to
understand if you can go through
the examples. So let's take a
look at what they had for an
example code that they recommend
not to do. It's exactly what I
was trying to do, where you take
a item and you try to
concatenate with plus signs. And
when you're done, you have a SQL
statement. So it's vulnerable to
hackers doing things that you
can do is called SQL injection
attacks. And I'm not going to go
into that right now. But if you
look in the description, I can
show you a course that deals
exclusively with SQL injection
and cross site scripting, all
kinds of security issues with
programming. But for right now
we're just trying to get this
thing to run. Let's go down and
we're gonna go past example two,
because it's doing the same
thing where we're concatenating
strings. And so we're trying to
find a solution. And sure
enough, it comes up with one. So
the solution is this. It's
called parameter queries. And
the way it looks like is that we
have to come up with something
that has an at symbol, and then
we use let's see, where is it?
We
Have something where we do
parameters right here. So we're
going to have a command that
looks like that parameters add
with value. So we're not going
to do the exact code here, but
something very close to it. So
take time to read this article.
And you'll be a lot smarter when
it comes to using a sequel app
and avoiding SQL injection
attacks. So to make this work,
we're going to split up our
command item here, our command
object and put some extra
parameters into it. So I'm
eight, I'm cutting out the
sequel string, and in the line
64, where it says, Make a new
command, I'm just going to leave
it with no parameters just to
parentheses. Then in the
following line, I'm going to say
I'm going to add a parameter
text or a command text to this,
and it is the SQL statement. And
I'm going to make sure that I
have the at search parameter in
there. So it's a placeholder for
something else. Then following
that placeholder, we're going to
put a new line in that says
command dot parameters dot add
with value. And then I can tell
the computer that at search is
really a substitution for this
search wild fruit. Another line
that we need to do is tell the
command what connection we're
using. So I'll say command dot
connection equals, and then we
have a string up above called
connection, which was defined
like way up at the beginning of
the of the of the class here. So
we have a connection, we have
parameters and command text.
Let's see if this works. So I
got the app running. And let's
try letter A, and do a search.
And we've got some results this
time. So it looks to me like
we've got exactly what we want.
So let's try and search for the
letter B again, and see what we
got. Let it be let's try the
word L E. And do we get anything
we got one song. And if I take
all of the items out and do a
search, we get the whole
results. So this to me looks to
like a search results that is
successful. Now in the next
video, we're going to add a
picture over here. So we're
going to have the album photo on
the screen, which is a pretty
simple case, we've already got
the image URL in our database.
Now can we make it show up on
the form? Well, the answer is
yes. And it's not very hard.
Hi, welcome back to another part
for our SQL application tutorial
we're doing here. In this video,
we're going to continue on
building the interface for our
app. So in the previous videos,
we've done all of these items
that you see on the screen,
we're at the point now where we
can search for an album in our
database. So what we're going to
do in the future is to continue
on to build all of these
features, until we have a
complete idea of how to use
MySQL. And so continue on and
will become a software developer
together. So let's take a look
at the application as we're
going to finish today. So you
can see we have a little icon on
the screen that shows a picture
of the album cover. And every
time I click one of the rows in
my table, you can see that the
album art is displayed over here
in the picture box. And so a
couple of things we're going to
have to do to make this happen.
First of all, we're gonna have
to put this picture box on the
screen, of course, the second
thing is that when we click the
grid, we're going to have to
find out what row we're in, and
what column we're going to get
the information from, and then
load that into the picture box.
So when all that's done, you'll
have yourself what you see on
the screen here. So let's get
started with a code. Okay, so
I've reversed the application.
So now the picture box is gone.
And we're ready to start adding
that feature now together. So
I'm going to close this and
start the process. So here's the
process, we're going to take
this form and put a picture box
on it. So let's go find the
picture box, first of all, and
let's see it's called picture
box right there in wind forms is
as simple as dragging something
onto the screen and changing the
size. Okay, so now let's check
to see if we can add something
to that box. So you can see that
it's it's empty right now. And
there's multiple ways to put a
picture into a box, what we're
going to do is use the URL from
one of our videos. So to get one
of the video URLs, I'm going to
go to the PHP myadmin page. And
then I'm going to find the,
let's say the first one here. So
let's do a CTRL A to Ctrl.
Select it all Ctrl C to copy it.
And then let's come back into
the Visual Studio. Now in here,
we're going to be able to add
this and I need some kind of an
event. To do that for right now.
I'm just going to choose Load
albums. And at the end of the
album, I'm going to load this so
let's see if I type in picture
one box one and then there is a
command for load I believe it is
yes.
So it's as simple as telling it
what URL you want. So I'm going
to put in a quotation marks.
Paste in the string and assign
Aculon. So that should load an
image from the internet, it's as
simple as that. So let's go
ahead and run it and test it
out. So when I click the Load
albums, you can hopefully see
there is the picture. So that is
Abbey Road. If I click any of
these things, it doesn't change.
So we've still got that to go.
And it appears that only the top
left corner of the album is
showing. So those are the things
that we still have to do. But we
have proven that we can load a
picture from the internet. First
of all, I want to change the
property of this picture. So
let's click here. And let's go
down to the bottom where it says
appearances. Now what I'm
looking for is a way to scale
this image. And I'm not quite
sure which one was. Here it is
it's called size mode. So right
now it's set at normal. And
let's look at the choices. So
stretch might be the first thing
you think of, but you can get
all kinds of weird warped
pictures. The one we're looking
for is zoom, and the others you
can experiment with. But for
right now, we're just going to
try zoom. And let's run it again
to check to check to see what
kind of a picture look that
looks like. So I click on Load
albums, and there I get the
whole photo. So it's scaled
proportionally. And it
automatically adjusts to the
frame. Very nice. So I'm not
really interested in seeing
Abbey Road every time I click
the grid, I want to see the
actual picture that I'm supposed
to get from the grid. So let's
click the grid once. Now, you
might be tempted to double click
the grid if you want an event to
occur. So that's like clicking a
button. But in this case, what I
want to do is to go to the
properties and choose the events
and look at my choices. So the
mouse has a click cell, click
contents and cell double click.
So let's do click cell. So I'm
in this square here, I'm just
going to double click here. And
now I have a sell click event.
This one works better than the
other two, I can guarantee you
that. But just take my word on
it. So now what I want to do is
check to see if this actually
works. So the simplest way to do
a test is to do a message box
and show it. Let's go ahead and
test it out. Okay, so I'm going
to load some albums. And then
I'm going to click something.
And sure enough, it says
clicked. So you can see I can
click on any cell in the grid
and I get a clicked message. Now
how can I tell which cell I
clicked right now it's just kind
of generally saying you click
the cell. So the key here is the
word sender. If you look into
the parameters that are the
click event has sender is the
item that is sending this
message. So I'm going to save
the sender as a data grid view
object. So I assume that the
sender is always the data grid
view. So I will just say that is
equal to the sender. Now you can
see that there's a problem. So
sender is a generic object. And
data grid view is a specific
type of object. So to make this
fix occur, it says, Would you
like to do a cast. So let's go
ahead and choose this and add
the explicit cast and tells it
now that I guarantee you that if
this receives a click event,
it's coming from a grid view. So
now I want to capture some
values about the grid. So for
instance, the row number, so
let's create an integer
variable, and name it row
clicked, we're going to get it
from the data grid view dot
current row dot index. So
current row is the current row
that's selected, and index is
the row number. And then I'm
going to do a message box to
show some feedback. So we can
see if this is actually doing
what we want, we want to get the
row number numbers. So let's go
ahead and click the Go button
and see what this message box
shows. So we show the album's
first and now when we click
something, you can see that it
says I clicked row number three,
now count these down. So Abbey
Road is zero, let it be as one
help us to and then Revolver is
three. So it is not showing me
the album ID number. It's
showing me the row number. So
this is row number zero. And
let's see what the last one is.
So it's not 17 it is row six. So
now that I have the row number,
I can go get the column. So if
you if you count the columns,
just like the rows we have ID is
zero. I will name as one artist
two,
years three, and image URL would
be fourth. So the fourth column
of the row that was clicked
contains the string that we want
to put in the picture box. Okay,
let's see if we can get all that
in code. Okay, so here's the
process. Now we're going to
create another string and it's
going to be called Image URL. So
we're going to get this from the
data grid view. And the type of
head help is really pretty much
all right on here. It's pretty
close. I want to get the data
grid view dot rows, and then in
square brackets tell it which
row number which is the row
clicked. Then I want to get the
cells so a little bit off on
this one but cells and I want to
get cells, the array of cells at
position four
And that's actually the fifth
column. And then I'm going to
get the value and then change it
into a string. And then I've got
myself the value that I'm trying
to put into the picture box.
Let's put a message box out to
test this one, and see if that's
doing what we expect. Let's run
it again. And check. Okay, away
we go. So we click on albums.
And let's click something. So it
says here, you click row two,
and the image URL is this thing.
Is that indeed what we're after?
So it looks like the Beatles
album cover. Oh, help. That's
the word. Help. Okay. Let's try
another one. Let's go to the
Abbey Road. And do we get
anything.
So we got zero. And then it
looks to me like Abbey Road is
in the filename. So we've we've
got the right URL. Now, all we
have to do now is put it into
the picture box. All right, so
I'm a little tired of hearing
these picture box, things show
up. So I'm going to comment them
out. So they're out of the way.
So the last statement that I'm
looking for is Picture Box, one
dot load. And then in
parentheses, I have to put the
string of that image. And so
that is a string that we just
created a minute ago. It's
called Image URL. So that should
load the picture every time we
click a cell. Let's give it a
shot and see what happens. Okay,
the album's are loaded now. And
let's pick somebody let's try
let it be. And it looks like it
help. And revolver, Rubber Soul,
they're all coming up. Nice. So
all of my pictures are being
loaded, based on the image URL
field that is over here in
column number five. So the next
video that we're going to do is
going to be inserting new
records. So we need to create a
little data input form and add
new albums as the user chooses
to. So let's do that in the next
step.
Hi, in this video, we're going
to continue on working with this
tutorial on the SQL database
application. So we've gone
through a few sections already.
And so we are about ready to do
inserts. So we've done
searching, we've done creating a
table. What we're going to do
now is add records to a SQL
database. And so we'll create a
form, and then we'll execute an
INSERT statement using SQL. So
here's the rest of the tutorial.
So make sure that you stick
around to watch the entire
thing. My name is shad Sluiter,
and I teach software development
at Grand Canyon University.
We're in the middle of a process
here to make you a software
developers so many of my
students have already graduated
and gone on to get great jobs.
And I'm trying to add you to the
list. So make sure that you
subscribe, or go to my website,
which is steady coding.org,
where you can see all of the
things that we do in class. So
welcome aboard. So now I'm going
to show you where we're going to
end at this video. So you can
see the application that we have
in front of us here now has a
data entry form. So I kind of
shoved it into the corner up
here on the left. And you can
see that I've already filled out
a whole bunch of items. Let's
see where I got that. So if I
switch back into Wikipedia,
you're going to see that I've
been copying information, such
as the description, and the
image URL, and the year. So we
have a new album to add to our
database. So I filled in all of
these fields here. So Sergeant
Pepper's Lonely Hearts Club Band
and the rest of the items. Now I
click the Add button, I get a
pop up that says there's been
one record inserted. Now I want
to either click Load albums to
see everything. And you can see
that number 19 is Sergeant
Pepper's or I can choose the
search. And you can see that as
also shows up here. So let's
just type in an S, G, and search
and we got one item. So it did
insert correctly. And now I can
search for it. So that's what
we're going to have by the time
we're done with this video. So
let's get started with modifying
our application to look like
this. Alright, so you can see
that I've got the application on
the screen as we left it in the
previous tutorial. Now it's time
to put in this insert form. So
I'm going to drag in a whole
bunch of things and arrange them
inside of a container. And then
we'll add some code. Okay, so
now it's time to set up the rest
of the controls on our form. So
let's put some space up here in
the upper left corner, so we can
add some input fields. First of
all, take the image for the
album and drag it over to the
right, so we create some space.
Now I'm going to use a control
container. So a container is one
that is kind of a grouping
thing. So we look in the
grouping section or the
container section. And we find
group box one, so we'll drag him
in. So the name of this form or
the sub form really is called
add album. So we'll set the text
to add album so that we know the
user knows what's going on. Now
I'm going to put in a bunch of
labels. So these labels are
going to indicate what we're
entering. So we're going to say
Skip the ID number. First of
all, just leave that out, we're
going to start with the album
name. And so let's put in an
album name, change the text
value to album name. And then
we'll do artists. And then we'll
follow it with a year and the
image URL and the description.
Now I want to arrange these. So
we'll set the left margin to be
all equal. And then we'll also
set it so that they're
vertically spaced. So there's
some controls up here in the top
in the ruler, or the in the
control bar, you might call it,
where you can do all of these
arrangements. So you don't have
to be very good at arranging
things, that computer will help
you with that. Next, we need to
put in some text boxes. So let's
drag in a text box for album
name. Now instead of leaving the
name as textbox, to as you can
see here, I'm going to change
the name of the control because
we're going to reference that in
our code. So my convention from
working with other types of
forms is to use a prefix on
every one of my controls. So TX
T indicates a textbox, and then
an underscore, and then a
description of what that's for.
So txt underscore album name, is
what I'll use for the next one
is Tx T underscore and we'll say
artist or album artist. And so
we'll put in another text box
for the year. And we'll set that
to be year and then TX T is the
prefix. Let's go with image URL
and description following the
same pattern. So TX T, is the
prefix that I always use. Now
you might have a different
process and many other tutorials
will lead you in another way.
But this seems to work for me.
Let's also arrange these so that
they're all nice and straight.
So we'll choose a left margin so
that they're all lined up to the
left. And we'll also spread them
vertically, then we can finally
maybe change the width, so they
all match, and then resize the
group box so it fits nicely. And
then let's try to squeeze it
into the upper left corner of
our form, we might have to move
some of the other controls out
of the way to make this happen.
But we will see that there might
be enough space there. Now this
is kind of a poor example of
user interface design. And we're
trying to squeeze everything
under one form, simply because
we're trying to make this as
easy to program as possible.
This is not the way that you
would probably want to treat
your users if you were making a
real app. Can you imagine if you
had a phone app with all of
these controls jammed on one
screen? Not a good idea. But
we're focusing in the database,
right? This is a sequel class,
and we're making the simplest
form possible. Okay, so we got
the form setup, now we need a
button, and then an event to go
with it. So that way we can talk
to the database. So the last
item is to stick in a button
called add. So let's create a
little more space in our group
box. And then we'll drag in a
button. And let's just set the
text of the button to the word
add. I'm going to double click
on the buttons. So that way we
have an event, a click event.
And now we're going to program
something in here that will talk
to the database. So the first
thing I want to do is capture
all of those text inputs and
create a new album object. So
let's define the new album
object. We'll call it album. And
I'm going to create a new one
using an inline constructor
here. So we're going to create
all of the properties except for
the ID. So the first item is the
name. So the name of the album
is going to get its value from
the text control. So now you can
see why I use txt underscore as
the prefix for all of my text
items. They're really easy to
find on this help when you do
type cyst. So TX T artists know
it's called album name, and then
we get the text property of that
textbox. The next item is the
artist name. And let's choose
the txt artists name and ensure
that you put dot txt, then we're
going to use the year now this
one is going to flag an error
because a year is an integer and
we're going to assign it a text
value. Don't worry, we'll come
back and fix this. So we're
going to get the text from the
input box, then we're going to
have an image URL. And we'll get
the same idea. So text image
URL. And then finally we have
the description. So now we have
all of the properties except for
the ID associated with something
from the form. So far, so good.
Now for that year, what are we
going to do for that? So the
command we're looking for is in
the integer 32 class. So we'll
type in int 32 dot, and you can
see that there is a method
called parse, and it's Its job
is to take a text field and
convert it into an integer. So
we'll just surround the text
property with parentheses and
use int 32 dot parse. This
should all work as long as the
user fills out the fields
correctly. So we're not doing
any error checking here.
Remember, this is a simple app,
and we're talking about the
database issues. And we're not
trying to make a
user application so much. Now
that we have an album class, we
can now try to add it to the
database. So we're going to
create a new instance of the
albums Dao, which is the class
that we created in previous
exercises. So we're going to
create the new instance. And
then I'm going to call on a
method that doesn't exist yet.
But we will create that in a
minute. So the method is add one
album, and in parentheses, we
use the parameter album, the one
that we just got from the form.
Now I am going to come back and
fix this underlying error. One
other feature though, I want to
do is have an integer result
come back from this method. So
that will tell me if an insert
was correct or not. So an
integer value of result is what
we're going to get. Now we're
going to come back and finish
this code a minute. But now we
have to go and code in the other
class, the album's Dao, because
right now, as you can see, we
have an underlying, so let's go
check the underlying. And it
says here, the album's Dao does
not contain a definition for add
one album. So we haven't
programmed that yet. Let's see
if we can get some help here. So
show potential fixes. And the
only fix that says is would you
like to create this. So sure
enough, I'll click it. And
somewhere someplace, somehow,
the error goes away, we need to
go find it. So I'm going to save
this and switch into albums Dao
and see what's there. So let's
refresh our memory from what was
here. So I scroll to the top,
and we have a class with get all
albums. Then we have another
method down here called Search
titles. And then finally,
there's a new one that was just
inserted for us called add one
elbow. Now, I'm going to copy
some of the code that we used in
previous examples, and then
we're going to modify it. So the
simplest code I can pick from is
the very first method called get
all albums. So I'll just copy
the contents of that method, and
paste it into my insert command
that I'm going to do here at the
bottom. Now, I'm going to erase
most of the code, but I do need
to keep around a thing like,
open the connection, and close
the connection and create a SQL
command. Now the SQL command is
going to be drastically
different. But it still is a
command. So I'll leave that
line. Now the command here is
going to have the select
statement. So let's delete the
select statement. And we're
going to replace it with an
INSERT statement. Now, I'm not
very good at SQL, or maybe we're
new at it, let's say, let's go
and have some help from our
MySQL admin page. So I have here
the admin page for the MySQL
server. And up at the top, there
is a SQL statement. So I'm going
to get some help from here. So
as you recall, we were able to
do SELECT statements with help
here, I'm going to choose the
insert button, and it gives us
an exact line, what we need to
use as a model. Isn't that
handy. So I'm just going to copy
the entire thing, and then
change it once we get into our
program. So let's copy here, and
then switch back into our Visual
Studio and paste it inside of
these quotation marks. Now let's
see what we need to change here.
So we have a statement that says
insert into albums. Well, that's
the table that we want to insert
into. And then you can see the
next section lists all of the
column titles that are in the
table. So which of these columns
titles are we inserting? Is the
answer all of them? Not quite,
we are treating the first column
differently, the ID number, we
don't want to provide an ID
number when we insert because
the table is set up to
automatically increment the
counter variable for ID. And so
in this statement, I'm going to
erase the first column. So Id
does not include itself here.
And so album title is the first
column. Now the rest of these
are valid. Now when we get to
the values here, I'm going to
also replace those, so let's
select them all. And let's
delete. Now instead, I'm going
to use what are placeholders so
I'm going to use an at symbol,
and then some name that refers
to this column. So referring to
the rest of these, we're going
to have the album title, and
then an ad for the artist name
and ad for the year. Then we're
going to have an ad for the
image URL and then an ad for the
description. So now it's time to
adjust the parameters. So the
command that we want to use to
associate a parameter, those add
symbols with the actual value is
this command dot parameters dot,
add with value. And then in
parentheses, we're going to have
two things.
The first is a string, which
says which parameter name are
you trying to associate. So the
first column is the album title.
So we'll put at album title. Now
the second item is the actual
value that we are using for the
insert. So we have a variable
called album. Where did that
come from? So the album dot
album name is coming from the
parameter up online 92. So when
this method is called, it has to
have an album supplied to it. So
we've got the actual data coming
in there. So that's this first
parameter, then we'll associate
one property of the object with
the first parameter in the SQL
statement. So the rest of these
parameters are going to be very
similar. So I'll copy and paste.
So we're going to copy and paste
and then we'll switch the next
one to artists. And the album
dot artists name is the actual
value, then we're going to go to
add year. And we'll get that
from the property of the album
year. Then the third one, or the
fourth one is image URL, notice
I'm using a capital letters so
that way they match exactly. And
then we're going to have the
image URL from the album
property. And then finally, the
description. So all of these
parameters should work. If the
user fills out the form
correctly, if they fill out the
form, in a bad way, if they put
in strings for the year, for
example, then the app will
crash. So remember, we're not
checking for errors in the input
field, we're making this a
simple user interface. So the
next item is we have to execute
the query. So let's type in
command dot execute. And there
the the one of the first
suggestions is called a non
query execute non query, that
means you're not selecting
anything, we're doing an insert.
So I guess that goes as a non
query. Now it says here, what we
need is a statement, it says
against the connection, and then
it returns the number of rows
affected. Well, that's very
handy, because we want to get
those numbers of rows affected,
and send it back. So let's
choose execute non query, I'm
gonna press tab, and then we
have the execution. Now we need
to save this. So let's put in a
new value value and call it
result. Or let's call it new
rows. And then we'll get it from
this execute non query. So that
works out well. Then finally,
when we want to return
something, we're going to return
the number of new rows. And
let's see if all of the errors
go away. I believe they do.
Good. Now, we're almost done.
But we need to go back to form
one. And let's see what we can
add after the insert. So the
results are here. So I'm going
to just put in a message box. So
I'm going to say message box
Show. And then we're going to
tell it how many different rows
were inserted.
Okay, so now we've got
everything set up, it looks like
we're ready to run. So we just
have to click the green button
and try it out. All right,
there's the beautiful looking
app, let's Minimize Visual
Studio. And let's go back into
our Sergeant Pepper's. Let's see
if we can use this. So I'm going
to select the first paragraph.
And let's put in the description
below. So my user interface
doesn't allow for much space.
But as you can see, I can put in
a very long text. So the image
URL, I'm going to work up the
from the bottom, so let's go and
right copy, right click here,
choose Copy Image address. And
let's paste that into the image
URL. The rest of these I think
we can fill out so what were the
other ones, we've got 1967 here,
and then the artists that looks
like the Beatles,
and then says a lot of typing.
So I'm going to copy that title
and paste that. Okay, all that
work. Now we're ready to click
the Add button. And what do we
get? It says one new row was
inserted. And let's choose a
load albums. And let's go to the
bottom and you can see that I've
put it in twice now. And so if I
click one of these, we get
ourselves the URL image that
seems to be loading. So I
inserted Sergeant Pepper's
twice, you probably get one if
you click the Add button, you'll
get two as well. And you get a
whole bunch of them if you click
it multiple times. The next
thing that we're getting to in
this tutorial series is creating
a foreign key. Because now that
we've got albums, we need to add
some tracks or individual songs.
And each song is of course
associated with an album, which
is going to require us to learn
how to make two tables and a
foreign key. So we're gonna get
started with foreign keys next.
Hi, and welcome back to another
section of our SQL database
application tutorial. I think
this is part eight, and we are
learning how to use SQL
databases. So here's the index
of everything that we've learned
so far. You can see that we've
created tables and we've created
a simple app that can read and
insert
records. In this video we are
going to talk about foreign
keys, you're going to learn how
to use a new tool that will
create links between tables. So
we will have an albums table,
and then another table in our
database for each of the songs,
we'll call it our tracks table.
And then the relationship
between them is very important.
And so we'll learn the how to
use the tool called MySQL
Workbench. So a lot of concepts
here about SQL databases that
we're going to explore. Right
now, here's the rest of the
sequence that we're going to
learn. So we're about halfway
through. And by the time you're
done, you will become a sequel
expert, we might say my name is
shad Sluiter, and I teach
software development at Grand
Canyon University in Phoenix,
Arizona, I'm glad you've joined
us. So many of the students that
I've taught in the past are now
employed very successfully as
software developers. So I'm
inviting you to come along and
learn some of the same things
that we do in class. In this
particular course, SQL
databases, you use this in
almost all types of software
development. So this is an
essential part of your
education. So make sure you
check out the website at steady
coding.org, where you can see
all of the courses that I've
been teaching in the past few
years. So here's a preview of
what we're going to do before
the end of the video, you can
see on the screen that I have a
new tool up. This is called my
sequel workbench. And a
workbench tool is used to design
databases. So by the time you're
finished, you're going to have
not only the album's table that
you see here, but this link to
another table called the tracks
table. And so this contains all
of the songs that each album
has. And you can see there's a
link between the two called a
foreign key. And so all these
concepts that we're going to
learn right now, so if you
haven't installed this tool yet,
let's go and find it. So I'm
googling MySQL Workbench
installs. So let's see what we
got here for one of the links.
And this is the one you want
here. So MySQL Workbench
Download Now. And then you're
going to have the choice of
which platform you want to
install. So I'm using Windows,
you might have something else,
but go ahead and choose the
download and go ahead and run
the setup. And when you're
finished, you will have the
application that you see on my
computer. So I've got the
application installed, I'm just
going to click the little
dolphin icon and run it. So you
can see the first screen is
welcome to my SQL workbench.
Now, I'm going to remove this
item here because you don't have
that yet. So let's see, delete
the connection, and click
Delete. So the first thing you
do when you launch this is try
to connect your MySQL Workbench
to a server. Now you can see in
the background that I have the
MAMP server running. And I have
the green dots indicating that
the two servers are active. So
the Apache server which honestly
we are not using, but it's are
automatically included in this
package. MySQL server is also
running. So the tool MySQL
Workbench will work with any
type of SQL MySQL server. So
whether you're installing MAMP,
or lamp or USB Web Server, or
you just installed MySQL as a
standalone product, they will
all be able to connect using
MySQL Workbench. So you might
have a similar setup that I do.
But hopefully it's something
that is as close as possible so
that the tutorial makes sense to
you. Alright, so let's see how
we can make this work. So as you
recall, the server here has a
user name and password. So root
is the username. And root is the
password for this particular
instance of MySQL. So that's
important to be able to connect.
Now I'm going to just minimize
this. And now we're going to go
into MySQL Workbench. So now
down here, in the section where
the mic SQL connections are
listed, I'm going to click the
plus sign. And this will add a
new connection. Now if you if
you don't find that plus sign,
you can probably find that over
here under the databases menu.
But I'm just going to go with
this plus sign. So I'm going to
set up a connection. So the name
of the server is localhost. So
that's a great name for the
connection. Down below here is
the IP address of my server. So
I'm going to type in localhost
again, you could leave it as
127 001. But localhost is
synonymous, then the port number
is 3306. So that's the default
port. And if you want to check
to see if you're running on that
port, you go to your map server,
go to the map menu, pick
preferences, choose ports, and
you'll see the port number
listed here. So this is 3306. So
I'm just going to cancel this
and minimize map. So I'm just
verifying that 3306 is the
correct number and it likely is
on your computer too. Now I'm
going to test the connection and
it says it was successful. So if
this is not
Successful check your passwords,
check to see if you've got the
right ports and everything.
Let's click OK, and choose OK
again. So now I've added a new
connection down here. So I don't
have to go through and set up
the connection again, the next
time I run this application, I
can just double click on this
gray box, which I'm going to do
now. So I've double clicked. And
hopefully I've connected. Now
you can see on the left side
here, I have two tables, I have
a music table and a music to
table. If you don't see that you
can switch because you might
have administration on this tab.
And then what I want to select
is schemas. So the schemas are
the database names. So let's
take a look inside of here. So
music two is the application
that we've been working on. So
I'm going to expand this, choose
tables. And you can see that
there's an albums table. So if I
were to expand that further, you
can see the column names. And
then you're going to see more
details about our, our design.
So we have ID, the title, the
artist, the year, the image and
the description. So those are
all the items that we set up in
the PHP admin page. And so you
can see the same kinds of
materials here. But my SQL
Workbench will do more
administration tasks and an
easier way than the previous
admin screen that we've been
using up until now. So what I
want to do is add a second table
and make a foreign key. So just
to see where we're going, I'm
going to collapse music, too.
And I'm going to show you what
music looks like because I
created this application
earlier, just to prepare for
this tutorial. So to show you
how this works, I'm going to go
to database, you won't be able
to do this yet. So just watch.
I'm going to choose reverse
engineer. And I'm going to click
Next. And then I'm going to log
in,
and then click OK. Now it says
you've connected, let's go
through this steps here. So
next, and it says which one of
the schemas would you like to
connect to. So music two is the
one we're currently using. I'm
going to take that one off, and
I'll show you the one that I
created an earlier tutorial. So
music is what I'm after. Choose
next, it says so far, so good
with green checkmarks. Next
again, it says you're going to
import to tables and execute.
And this time when I'm done,
something happened in the
background, I click Next. And
then finally I click Finish. And
here we are. So now you can see
the results of what we're trying
to get to. So I have two tables,
I have an albums table and
attracts table. So that's where
we're going. Now let's back up
and see if we can get to this
point. So I'm going to close
these tabs at the top of the
screen. And don't save
whatever's there. And we're
back. So I want to open up the
music to database. So let's try
this again. This time you work
with me. Alright, so click on
database, choose reverse
engineer.
And then we're going to choose
Next,
we're going to choose Next,
we're going to select music to
choose Next,
choose next.
Execute.
And next, and finally finish.
Okay, so all of that work gets
us to this diagram. So what
we're looking right now at is a
diagram called an E R diagram.
This is the design of your
database. You can see it has one
table, and it shows you all the
column names in it. Now we're
going to add a new table and
then resynchronize our database
to this diagram. So there's a
couple of steps involved here.
And you have to do it exactly
right. Or it will give you an
error. So first of all, we're
going to create a table. So over
here in this column here, you
can see that there is an icon
that says place a new table. So
I'm going to click it and then
click out here. And I got table
one. So table one doesn't have
anything in it. Of course, it
looks kind of like a title only.
Let's double click it.
So when I double click it, I get
a another bunch of things that I
can configure. The first thing
is I'm going to give it a name.
So let's call this thing tracks
and press enter. Now what are we
going to have in the tracks
table, let's go down to the
columns. So the first thing you
usually do is you set up an ID
and leave it as an integer.
We're going to check auto
increment as our option. The
next item down. So the next item
down I'm going to call it track
title. And so I'll use an
underscore character here. You
don't have to use underscore,
you can just shove them all
together into a single word if
you like. But I would recommend
that you do not use spaces in
any of your column names. So
this is going to be a VAR char
type of column. And since the
title of the album is probably
Longer than 45 letters, let's
set it to something bigger. I'll
choose 100 characters. So let's
add some other items. So after
the title, let's put in another
column, and we'll call it
number. So this is the track
number, like if it's track
number one on the album, so it's
an integer. So usually there's
about eight to 10 tracks per
album. So we'll see some number
between one and 10. The next
item down that we're going to
put is a string. So this is
video underscore URL. So this
will be a YouTube link so we can
actually play the video. So a
number of characters that we're
going to need here is what maybe
200 or so how long is the URL
for a YouTube video, I'm not
quite sure. So 200 is a safe
number.
Let's add a lyrics column. So
the lyrics will be the other
words to the song. And for some
reason, we might want to print
that to the screen. So a lyrics
could be really long. So look at
all of the options for our
different data types. So there's
a lot of different options for
choosing a text field, I'm going
to choose the one that has text
and a parenthesis. So I can
specify that it has some number
of items, let's say 2000. Is
that enough letters for a song,
I think it might work. So we'll
use text. And then that's the
last one we're going to put. So
it looks to me like I have a
couple of extra columns here
that I didn't mean to do. So
let's go and select the item
that was accidentally put in
there. I'm going to right click
on it and choose Delete. And
then let's do the last one as
well. And so now we're down to
just a few different columns
here. Okay, so all of this here
is I think, correct. So I can
close this tab. And you can see
the changes occur here. Now,
this is not quite finished,
we're missing the link between
these two columns, or between
these two tables. So let's go
look at these items here. So
these are different links. If I
want to have a relationship, I
can have a one to one
relationship, or a one to many.
Here's another kind of one to
one and another kind of one to
many, many to many
relationships. So complex
relationships can be modeled
here in MySQL Workbench. The one
I'm looking for is this one that
says a it's got a dotted line on
it, I always do this backwards,
so I might have to delete my
links, but I'm going to try it
anyway. So I'm going to click
once here. Now I'm not holding
the button down, I just clicked
once. And I'm gonna go click a
table. So let's try this one,
and then click this table, and
it creates a link between them.
And sure enough, it's backwards.
So look at the little marks at
the end of the row. And this was
this is why I know it's
backwards. This says that on the
side here is a triple link, it
looks like a bird's foot. And
the other side has a single
link. So that means that for
every one track, there are many
albums. So that's backwards,
because the opposite is true.
Each album has many tracks. And
each track belongs exactly to
one album. So I messed up. So I
did that on purpose, actually,
because I wanted to show how to
delete an item because it's so
oftenly done incorrectly. So I'm
selecting the line there. And
I'm pressing Delete on the
keyboard, it didn't work. Let's
try right click and choose
Delete then. And it says you
want to delete this
relationship. And I say delete,
and it's gone. Let's try it the
other way. So I'm going to click
here again. This time, I'm
clicking on the track and then
back to the album. And as you
can see, now the relationship is
the opposite direction. So we
have a single album matches with
many tracks. And then here
there's a new item. It is the it
says at the bottom albums ID. So
this is the foreign key. The
Foreign Key says we're going to
store a number in the table that
tells us which album we belong
to. So each album has an ID
number. And each track has an
associated album to go with it.
Okay, so that is our model. Now
we're going to try to
synchronize this to our
database. Now when we do this
synchronization, we're going to
encounter an error. And I'm
going to leave the error on the
screen because it's so common.
And so we'll fix that up. So the
first time we do this, it will
not work. But here's the
attempt. So if I want to
resynchronize my database, I
click here. And I can choose two
things I can choose forward
engineer which will erase my
current database and replace it
with a model on the screen. Or I
can try synchronize model now
where is that so synchronized
down here. So this is the one
that I prefer. So let's try
synchronize. Now we're going to
see the same choices here. We
have a server number and then a
password so we have not updated
the database yet. This is the
process of changing
The model in our database. Let's
see, click next.
Now, I'm not going to do any of
these checks here. So click Next
again, it says make sure that
you connect. So I type in the
word root for my password. Click
OK. Says that was correct. Let's
go to next again. Now it says
which database are you trying to
synchronize. And so I am using
music too. Let's click Next
again.
And it says it's connected.
Let's click Next. And now you
can see a preview of what's
going to change. So the albums
and tracks tables are currently
in the design that I just drew,
we're going to synchronize it
with the database, which has a
existing albums table. And then
the second item is a new table.
So when I select one of these,
you can see that there is a
statement below. So this is the
SQL statement that is going to
be executed, if you wanted to
use the command prompt and type
all of this out, you could,
you'd have to know every single
type of exception and option to
be able to type this correctly,
which is why I always use MySQL
Workbench, because honestly, I
can't remember all of these
things very well.
So this isn't going to work. But
we're going to try it anyway. So
let's click Next.
And it gives us the preview. So
preview the changes. So it's
going to say I'm going to create
a table, the table is going to
be called tracks, it's going to
be in the music to database,
it's going to have all of these
columns, and then it's going to
have some primary keys going on
here. And this problem right
here, the word visible is going
to cause our problem to halt.
It's not going to work. And I'll
show you why. So let's execute,
login.
And you can see we have a
problem. So this is so common
people Google this all the time
to find out. Why can't I
synchronize? It doesn't tell me
why. It just says there's a
problem. And here's what the
problem is. So we're going to
close this. So the
synchronization failed. Here's
what the problem is, we have a
version number here. So if I go
to Edit, and preferences,
and then I select the modeling
my sequel, we're going to have a
version number. So this tool is
set up to synchronize with
MySQL, eight dot something 8028.
Now, if you already have version
eight on your computer, then you
didn't receive any errors. But
more than likely, you have an
older version like I do. So
let's go and check out MAMP and
see what version we're running.
So I click here, choose MAMP
preferences. And let's go to
server does it tell us here it
does. So our database server is
running version 5724. So you can
see the difference now, version
eight, version five, it doesn't
work. So I have to tell my
sequel workbench that this is
the version I am targeting 5724.
So I'm going to come back to
here and type that in. So I
could probably just type in 5.0.
So I have to actually set this
to version five to perhaps I
just had an error when I tried
five to seven. So let's try 5.2.
And now I'm ready to synchronize
the models. So the two tables
are here. And this ER diagram is
on the screen. If for some
reason you want to save this
diagram, you can you can go to
File and Save. And if you lose
it, you can bring it back.
Anyway, I'm going to go to the
synchronized now. So let's
choose database. And let's try
synchronize the model. And then
we're going to log in and try to
see what happens. So let's see
put in our password. And choose
Next, making sure that's music
to is selected. Next again, next
again,
previewing the settings here. So
if I click here, you're going to
scroll down and see the same
thing except for this index no
longer has the word visible in
it. That's the change between
SQL, MySQL five and MySQL eight,
at least in this one case. So
let's click Next. And let's
preview it if you want, you can
see all the commands and then
choose execute. This time there
are no errors. So I'm feeling
better about this. Let's go
ahead and choose Close. So we
have now a foreign key. Now
let's go back to our other tool.
This is the my admin tool from
PHP. So I'm going to collapse
music and look at music too. So
let's go ahead and create click
this green arrow or refresh the
page either one and let's see
what comes up now. So I open up
the schema called Music two and
now I have two items here I have
albums and that looks the same
as it did before no change but
I have tracks. So now I want to
insert some items into the
tracks table. So I'm going to
pick one of the album's that
I've already looked at. And I'm
choosing Abbey Road. I hope that
Wikipedia has a list of the
songs here on lb Abbey Road.
Okay, here's one. So come
together is one of the songs. So
I'm going to insert some data
here into my table. So I'm going
to copy come together, and then
switch back into my, my PHP
admin. So I'm in the tracks
table. And I'm going to choose
Insert. And the track title, I'm
going to paste that in. So come
together is the name. So the
number on this thing, it's track
number one and the album. And
now I need a video URL. So the
video URL that I'm looking for
is on YouTube, of course. So
let's, let's play the song here.
And you can see that I've got
the right one. So this has come
together. So I'm going to just
swipe the URL from the command
bar or the URL address bar here
at the top and choose Copy.
Let's stop that. And now I'm
going to go back and insert it
here where it says Video URL. So
it's just a text string, but it
will link us to a video. So how
nice is that? Okay, down here,
the lyrics don't have the
lyrics. So I'm looking for the
lyrics. So I Google it. And sure
enough, here comes a whole bunch
of stuff. So let's go ahead and
copy all of this words that
Google gives us. And let's try
that. Okay, so I'm gonna copy
this, and paste it into the
lyrics section. So now I have
come together Yeah, as my
lyrics. And then the finally we
have a foreign key. So when I
choose an album number, it's
going to save, I'm going to
force you into one of these
albums. So you can see the
bottom group here has the number
of the album listed first. So
three in Abbey Road, the top
group is reversed. So Abbey,
road three is the order, you can
pick either one of these, and
they'll both work. So I'm going
to choose three and choose go.
Now this insert command was
successful, you can see that
there was one row inserted. And
then it gives me the SQL
statement that was done here. So
all of this here is what I
didn't have to type, it did it
for me. But you can see the
statement and how the work goes.
So it's insert into the tracks
table. It lists all of the
column names, and then the
values. So you notice the no
value for ID is listed. So
that's auto increment. The rest
of the stuff is all things that
we just entered in the form. So
come together, one, the URL and
everything else. So that is how
to insert. Let's go ahead and
browse the table, and you can
see that we have one item come
together. So here's your
homework, I need you to put in
two or three different tracks
for each of the albums in your
collection. So use the same
process that I did go looking on
Wikipedia or wherever else you
can find the resources. And
especially make sure that you
get the video URL from something
on YouTube. And then we're ready
to go on to the next step. In
the next part of the video,
we're going to use table joins.
So we created a foreign key. And
now the next step is to select
items using that foreign key to
be able to use in our
application. So we're moving
ahead, and you're getting
Smarter Every Day with SQL see
in the next video.
Hi, welcome back to another
tutorial in our SQL database
application. In this tutorial,
we're going to work with joins.
So if you look at the table of
contents of all the things that
we've learned, we're up to the
end of row two here. So table
joins is the ability to take two
tables and put them together.
Here's the entire playlist of
everything that we're learning,
so make sure that you stick
around for the rest of it. My
name is shad Sluiter, and I
teach software development at
Grand Canyon University. So I'm
welcoming you to come to class
with me in this virtual ways so
that you can become a
professional developer. So let's
get started with this next
section. So this is how the
application is going to look by
the time we're done with this
video. So you can see that if I
click an item, up on the top
section, I have an album title.
And then when I click it, the
bottom table is refreshed so
that it includes the tracks. So
for instance, the help album has
three tracks and it has helped
the the night before and then
Ticket to Ride. So I can't play
the video yet. There's going to
be a video player over here
soon. So this is where we're
going we're gonna have a second
table of data that depends on
the items that are in the first
table. So in the first section
here, we're going to add a few
items to our form. So let's
start with the user interface.
is designed. So the first thing
I need to do is add a label and
then another grid view. So I'm
just going to drag in a label.
And then after I put it there,
I'm going to give it a new name.
So it's going to have the text
as tracks. And then below that,
let's put in a new data grid
view class or a new object. And
we'll resize it so that we leave
some space over on the right
side, because we're going to put
a video player there eventually,
but not in this video, but
coming up soon. So that's the
only changes we have to make to
the user interface. So the most
of the work here and this part
is going to go in the code where
we fetch data. So the part I
want to work on first is in the
album's Dao. So let's just
refresh our memory what albums
Dao has, I'm going to select the
first item and collapse it, and
then the second method, and so
we have search, we have ADD, and
we have get all so those are the
three things that we see here.
So we're going to make a another
item here that will fetch all of
the tracks from the database
that match an album. Now, if you
recall from the previous
tutorial, we created this
foreign key relationships so
that way, we have tracks that
have an album ID number in their
table. So that's how we're able
to make this work. So I like to
reuse code and then manipulate
it so I don't have to type so
much. So I'm going to copy all
of the lines for the method for
searching for albums. So let's
select everything from the top
to the bottom. And I'm going to
paste this new method down at
the bottom of the class, then
I'd have no need to rename it.
So I go back up to line 122, it
looks like in my file, and I'm
going to name this thing as get
track for album or get tracks
for album. And the parameter
that we're going to expect to be
provided here is an integer. So
we're going to get the album ID
and return a list of tracks. So
that'll be similar to searching
for a name, but a few changes.
So let's make those changes now.
So the first change we're going
to make is we're going to return
a list of tracks instead of a
list of albums. So I replaced
the word album with track. And
you can see that the computer
doesn't know what a track is
yet, we haven't defined that.
We've just made a database full
of tracks, but we haven't given
an object to our application. So
usually those two things go
together. So let's make one. So
I'm going to go to the
suggestions. So I hover over
track and shows potential items.
And it says here generate track.
And it says Where would you like
to put that I'm going to select
the first item, which is in a
new file. So I select that. And
then over here, you can see that
track is now defined. So it has
no properties, we can put those
in now. But that was just one
way to make a new class. So
let's go put all the properties
in that are in our database. So
the first property of the class
is the ID number, which is an
integer. And then I'm going to
get the next suggestion, which
is a string with a name. So the
name of the track is our second
property. The third property is
going to be the number which is
the track number on the album,
which is an integer. And then we
go on to the video URL, the
video URL is a string. And then
finally, we have a lyrics
property, which is also a
string. So we define all these
things. And now we're able to
create new instances of tracks.
So let's go ahead and save this
and go back into the DAO class.
So I switch back into Dao. And
you can see that now track is
defined. So there is no error on
line 125, we're not going to do
any searching by name. So I'm
going to delete this wild
phrase. Now here's where the
main part is going to take
effect. So we are going to erase
this select statement and change
it with another one. So what I
want to select then is every all
the columns, so star from the
tracks table, and I'm going to
have a WHERE statement where we
have a match of the album ID to
some placeholder here, so we'll
call it at album ID. So let's
double check to make sure I got
the right column name here,
because I'm not quite sure that
album ID is what I actually
chose. So let's go back into the
MySQL admin and take a look at
tracks. And you can see that
albums underscore id over here
is the actual name. So that's
incorrectly typed in my code. So
let's correct it here. And
they'll say, albums underscore
id make sure that the column
name matches this property here.
The next line down we have to
define what the parameter is. So
it's at albums ID is the
placeholder that I used in the
previous line. And then I have a
parameter called album ID. Now
just to prove that I got that
right, let's scroll up just a
few lines to see where that
comes from. So that's coming
from here on line 122
So we're passing an integer in,
which has to be valid. So we're
going to get down to the for
loop now or the while loop where
we do the reading of each line.
We're no longer reading albums,
this is adapting to tracks now.
So let's change the type from
album A to B track, and we'll
use T for a placeholder name.
Now we can erase all of the
properties that we used for
album and replace them. So we'll
go through the list of the
anything that's in the table.
First of all, it's the ID, then
it's the name, then it's the
number, then I believe it was
the URL for the video. And then
finally, the lyrics. And so
those are all properly given to
us with this nice type ahead
help from Visual Studio. The
last item where we add something
to the list of return these is
instead of a, we're going to
change it to T because we're
changing tracks. Now it looks
like I'm done, except I've got a
strange error at the bottom.
Let's see what that is all
about. It says here, we've got a
problem. It says you're trying
to return tracks, and you were
promising albums. So let's
scroll up to see at the top of
the function to see what's going
on here. So in this line here on
122, the datatype for the return
says album, and that's supposed
to be tracks. So I think that's
everything we need. So this
function here, or this method,
should be able to fetch all the
tracks given an albums ID
number. Now, we can't test this
out yet in the user interface.
Otherwise, I would go and run
it. Now, we need to add
something else. So that way we
can produce the proper output.
Okay, so let's start at the top
now of our form one program and
look what we did to set up the
data grid view, we had to have
something called a binding
source. So let's create a
binding source for the second
grid. So I'm going to name this
thing as tracks binding source.
And we'll just instantiate a new
instance of it.
Let's do some other code. So if
you looked at this button,
click, we had a data source from
the get all albums and then
assigned it to the binding
source. So we're not going to go
through all that again, I'm just
going to borrow this and modify
it. So let's copy here. And
let's come down to the bottom.
Now, whenever we click the grid,
we want to be able to update the
binding source for the second
grid. So let's go ahead and
paste in some things that we had
before. So instead of albums
binding source, I'm going to
have it as tracks binding
source. And then you can see
that album's Dao is undefined
inside of this function. So
let's create a new instance of
it now. So we got a new
instance. And then we're going
to redefine the function that
we're using just on the next
line. So the function that we
created earlier, or the method
is called Get tracks for album.
And then inside the parentheses,
we need a, we need an album
number, well, we've just clicked
something on the grid. That's
why we're in this function here.
And we need to get something
from the click. So we have it
right up here. It's on row 45.
This is telling me which row was
clicked. So we'll just use that.
So what I want to get out of the
data grid is the number or the
ID number of the album. So I can
get that by saying go to the
data grid view, get the rows,
tell me which row was clicked,
then I'm going to get columns
zero, so that is cells, bracket
zero, and then give me the value
of that. So that should be an
integer because the first column
tells me the ID of the album.
Now you can see there's a
problem here, it says, I'm
getting the value, but it's not
guaranteed to be an integer. So
let's come down to show
potential fixes. And choose Add
explicit cast. And so what's
this little thing in the front
here, it says, make sure that
this is an integer, and then
we'll convert it into something
that we can use to look up by an
integer. The next line down says
instead of data grid view to
one, let's change it to two. And
instead of the album source,
let's change that to tracks. So
it's the track
tracks binding source. Okay, so
that apparently is going to
work, I'm going to cross my
fingers and see what happens.
Okay, got the app up and
running, I'm going to try
loading the albums. And they
show up here. Now I'm going to
click on Help. And you can see
that it went to the database and
selected three items. So each of
these has a various numbers of
tracks in them. So this shows us
the track and all of the
properties that are there. Now,
we're not quite done yet,
because I wanted to show you
what foreign keys can do when it
comes to joining tables. Okay,
so that kind of takes us to the
end of this part where we're
trying to put two tables on the
screen. We didn't do exactly
joins in this lesson, but we did
use results from two different
tables. So that kind of gets you
one step further to the end. Now
take a look at what's coming up.
We're going to do UML diagrams
and a few other things. So stick
around, and we'll keep learning
SQL together.
Hi, and welcome back to another
part for our SQL database
application. In this section,
we're going to continue on with
table joins. So if you've been
following along, we're here at
the end of row two of our
contents. So table joins is what
we're going to be working on,
you can see that we still have
four more subjects that we're
going to cover. And by the time
you're done, you'll be an expert
with working with SQL databases.
My name is shad Sluiter, and I
teach software development at
Grand Canyon University. And
you're in the middle of a
process of learning how to write
sequel applications. So let's
take a quick overview of where
we're going to be by the end of
this video. So what you see on
the screen here is the database
of our songs. And as you can
see, when I click one of the
album titles, the rows below
show us the tracks. Now this is
different than the previous
lesson that we did. You can see
that the track titles here
include things like the album
title, and it's listed three
times here for in this case, the
word help. And then you can see
the other show the same results.
So what we're going to do is
have custom headers for this
bottom table. So you can see
that there's more table headers
here that are actually saved in
the database. So how are we
going to do that? Well, it's
through the magic of join. So
the first part of this tutorial
is to work with the MyAdmin tool
to create the joins, and then to
be able to put them into the
application as you see it here.
So let's get to the first part,
which is, what is a join. So
let's jump back into the tools
where we were designing two
different tables and connecting
them with a foreign key. So look
at this example here. So we have
tracks as one table, and albums
as the other table. And this
link, the foreign key shows us
that these two tables are
related based on a number that's
saved in each of these columns.
So the albums underscore ID
value here on the right always
matches with one of the numbers
in the ID column of the albums
table. That's the foreign key.
And we're going to use it to
create joints. So I'm going to
jump now into the PHP myadmin
page. And you can see that I
have the tables for albums and
tracks listed here. So we have
contents in both tables. So
there's actually values to be
able to search for now I'm
selecting the tracks table, and
then I'm going to the sequel
tab. And we're going to write a
select statement. So let's click
on the word select. And you can
see that we have all of the
column names listed for our
suggestion. And then it says
here from the tracks table,
let's choose the Go button, and
just check to see if it's
actually working. And so it says
we have 11 different items that
have been selected. So now let's
experiment with changing this
select statement into a join. So
I'm going to select again. And
then I'm going to put in
something at the very end. So
we're going to get rid of the
where clause for a second. And
then I'm going to say join. So
there is a join. And I'm going
to tell it the name. So the
album's table, and then you have
to say the word on so after the
word en then you put in the name
of the foreign key. So if I type
in here albums ID, and then
you're going to say equals
albums, and then you have.id. So
that's telling it which items in
the table contain a foreign key
and two, which one it's
associated with. So how did I
know to use those two? Well, I
have this diagram in my mind
where I see that albums
underscore ID is supposed to
equal albums.id, which is the
item on the left. So it's always
a good idea just to check to see
if you've written everything,
this will not change the results
here. But I just want to make
sure I haven't caused an error.
So I'm going to check, retain
the box and go. And sure enough,
I do have an error. What's let's
see if we can understand it. It
says down at the bottom, it says
column ID in the list is
ambiguous. Now that's an
ambiguous error. I don't know
what you mean. What that means
is that there are two tables
here. And both of them have an
ID column. So if you look at the
at the diagram, you can you can
see that right away. So tracks
ID and albums ID are both called
ID. And when we join tables, it
really wants us to be very clear
to say which table we're talking
about. So let's do that. Let's
specify which table so let's
scroll up and the problem is
occurring here where it says
select ID so it doesn't know
which table to get it from now
because we can select from both
tables. So let's put in here the
word albums that's the name of
the table and then.id so that
will be one selection. We could
also say give me the tracks dot
i
Add. And that is also valid.
Let's do the Go button now and
see what comes up. So now the
results are valid, you can see
that it says id and id. And we
can't really tell which one is
which. So this is a case of
being ambiguous, it would be
easier for us to understand the
results, if we didn't have just
the word ID. So since it is kind
of difficult to distinguish the
two, I'm going to rename them.
So I'll say, select albums.id as
and then I'll put a new label
and a good name for this could
be album ID. And the same goes
with the track ID. Let's now
rename it as again using the
keyword as, and we'll say
tracks.id As Track ID. Now let's
let's go again and see what that
does. So scrolling down, I see
the results. And now it is very
clear to say I know that the
first column is the album ID.
The second column is the track
ID, that makes more sense. So
the neat thing about joins is
that you can select columns from
either table now, and they will
show up in the results. So let's
say I wanted to, for some
reason, add the album title to
each row in the search results.
So I can just put in there, put
in albums dot album title. So
what does that do? Let's choose
go. And let's see the results
now. And you can see that album
title now is listed here. So
every row contains the album
title along with the rest of the
items for each track. So we're
selecting tracks, but we're
adding the album title as the
search results. Now I'm going to
reduce the number of columns
that we're selecting, because
that's a lot. So I'm going to
remove a few things. So let's
get rid of the first item, which
was the album ID, let's get rid
of that number. And I'm not sure
what else I'm going to get rid
of. But I'm going to delete
several of them to reduce it. So
that way when we do the search
results, now I click go, we have
a fairly narrow items. So I have
track title, track title, video,
URL, and lyrics. So those are
the results from this particular
query. Now I'm going to take
this query and attempt to use it
in my application. Okay, so now
it's time to take that SQL
statement that was using a join.
And we're going to bring it into
the application and see what
consequences that has. So what I
want to do is in this form,
whenever we click an album
title, I get the search results
of the tracks below. So right
now, it just shows a list of
tracks, which was working, but
we've changed the SQL query. So
let's see what that does. So I'm
going into the data access
object here. And I'm going to
copy the part that says Get
tracks for albums. So let's
select everybody all the way to
the last item and Ctrl C for a
copy, and then paste it. Now I'm
going to make some changes here.
And so let's just rename this
one as get tracks using join. So
right now as an identical piece
of code, get tracks using join,
we're going to have to change
the SQL statement now. So the
select statement comes from
here. So we have this nice
statement that does join. So
before I take this one step
further, I just want to add a
WHERE statement, I'm going to
say where album's ID, and I'm
going to put in something like a
three. So it's a placeholder
three is a placeholder. So
let's, let's try that out,
choose go. So the results are
that every item comes from
album, number three, which is
Abbey Road. So that is the
results because I said give me
ID equals three. So let's take
this as our example. I'm going
to copy that. So now let's jump
back into the code here. And I'm
going to erase this select
statement that was there and
paste over top of it the newest
version. So we've got albums ID
equals three. So the three isn't
quite what I want, I want to
have this placeholder album ID.
So that way, whatever we asked
for will match the album number.
Okay, so we got a bunch of
columns that are selected, and
then we return a track and then
hopefully we return the Okay, so
now I'm going to come back into
the form one, and I'm going to
change this code here. So this
method was get tracks for album.
Let's see what up there is. Now
let's try get tracks for album
using join. That's the new
method that I created. So should
work, right I'm selecting let's
see what happens when I run it
and what surprises might await
me. So I run the application, I
choose Load the albums, and then
I'm going to select help, and we
got a problem. So you can see
here that the track has, what
five different properties. And
when we did a select with a
joint statement, all of a sudden
we're selecting like six or
seven column numbers. So you
can't just say put these column
numbers into the properties of
the track object anymore. They
just don't match anymore. We
can't We can't use this process
as it's written. So I'm going to
fundamentally change what this
method is supposed to return. So
right now it says give me a list
of tracks. That's what the
return
earned value is on line 169. So
what I want now instead is a
something called the J object.
And let's see if we can do that
it's probably going to cause a
problem. So I type in J object.
And sure enough, it says I have
no idea what you're talking
about. So J object is something
working with JSON text, which is
a very flexible way to create
objects. And C sharp doesn't
automatically know how to work
with JSON, you have to install a
library. So let's go down to the
package installer, it says,
Newton soft JSON. And we'll
install whatever it says is the
most current package, and the
error goes away. Now let's check
to see what was installed. So
I'm going to right click and
choose Manage NuGet packages.
And let's check to see Yep, sure
enough, we got Newton soft, or
Newtown soft, and it's installed
here at version 1301. So now,
instead of returning a bunch of
tracks, I need a bunch of J
objects. So down here in the
reader area, we're going to
expect to add a new item, which
is going to be of type J object.
So you're going to see what a J
object is in a minute, I'm going
to print it so you can actually
see them. So for right now just
let you know that it's a very
flexible object, it's kind of
like making a track object or an
album object, except it has a
flexible number of columns and
properties. So we're going to
create a new one, it's called
new track. And then I'm going to
add it to my list of return
items. So it says here, you got
a problem. So new track is not
the right type. So let's scroll
up a little bit. And I have a
list of things called tracks
here. And let's change that to J
object. And that way will be
compatible.
Okay, so return these is of type
J object. Okay, so the errors go
away, we're not quite done, we
need to get all of the
properties from each column name
yet. And so that's what we're
going to do here. Okay, I need
to cut that out and put it in
the while loop. So we're going
to make a new object and then
add it to the list. So for each
column that I select, or each
column that I read, I'm going to
put it into this J object. So
I'm going to make a for loop.
And I'm going to say go from for
i equals zero to the length or
the field count of the reader.
So the reader read a row, and it
has a bunch of columns in it.
And the property called Field
count tells me exactly how many
columns there are. So it's a
flexible amount.
Now I want to add some rows, or
I am going to add some
properties to my new track
object here. So I'm going to say
new track dot add. Now we need
two things, we need a property
name and a property value. And
we can get those from the
reader. The first is to get the
readers name property for this
thing. So let's say reader dot
get name at column i. So i goes
from zero to the number of
columns. And so that will be a
string. That will be the first
half of the property, the second
half is the value. So to get the
value, we have a similar item,
we say reader dot get value at
position i. So that means we
have two parts to each column,
we have its column name, plus
its property value. All right,
so check all that out. I think
we got the columns all correctly
now. So this will be flexible
for the number of columns that
we're reading. And then we're
going to return it to our our
other part of the application.
So let's go to form one. So now
we come back into our form one,
and let's see what happens when
I run this. So now I click on
Load albums, and I get everybody
and I click on Help. And this
time, you can see that the
select statement is only
selecting a few rows. So we have
fewer items across there, but
they're flexible in number. So
if I change the columns that I'm
selecting, the bottom tables
should be flexible as well. So
let's test out that theory. So
I'm going to come back down to
here, and I'm going to for
whatever reason is I'm going to
leave out the lyrics. So let's
just delete lyrics. And we have
one less column. Let's run it
and see if that is as responsive
as I promised that it would be.
So here we go. Let's load the
album's. And we try help again.
And sure enough, the lyrics
column is gone. So I just didn't
need it for this part of the
application. So you can add more
columns and subtract columns to
the magic of this JSON object.
So this is not only a lesson
here and running sequel, but a
little bit in C Sharp and how
JSON text is handled. So JSON is
pretty common, you can see that
the advantage is that you're no
longer tied to the static number
of columns in a thing like this,
like the track or if we created
a custom class called a data
transfer object or a DTO, which
takes the number of columns and
into effect. So JSON was
invented to work with
JavaScript, but all other
languages, including C sharp
have adopted it, and you can see
the flexibility of it. So we've
moved on to another section. So
let's get to the bottom row now
and continue to learn about our
SQL application.
shins, we're going to talk about
UML diagrams, and how they are
used in design. That's coming up
next.
Hi, welcome back to another
piece of our SQL application
tutorial. In this part of the
video, we're going to pause on
the coding and talk about
design. So the subject is u m l
diagrams. Now most students of
mine would say that design is
not the thing that they would
prefer to do, but I forced you
to do it because it turns you
into far more organized in your
mindset, and your projects
turnout on time, and with far
fewer errors. So it's good to
invest the time my name is shed
Sluiter and I teach software
development at Grand Canyon
University. So you can check out
my tutorials on steady
coding.org. Or you can subscribe
to my channel. So the first
thing I want to show you is a
UML diagram for our current
application. So you're familiar
with our music app. So this
diagram shows two classes that
hold our data. So you can see on
the left side, we have an albums
class, and the right side is a
track class. So these are in the
C sharp code. This is not
necessarily in the database yet,
but they're very closely
related. Here's another diagram,
this is called an ER diagram or
an entity resource diagram. And
this should look familiar to
because we built this directly
out of the MySQL workbench tool.
And so you can see that there
are two tables joined by a
foreign key. Now you're supposed
to see that these are very
closely related in this case. So
this isn't always the case.
Sometimes Java classes or C
sharp classes have a lot more
methods and properties in them.
So the bottom line here where it
says method have pretty much
ignored because we're just using
these classes to hold data. So
UML is on the left, er is on the
right. Now, you'll also see that
there are some different
connectors between the classes.
So classes can be associated,
they can have aggregation, and
they can have composition. So in
the first case, if we were to
say a bicycle as a class, it
could be associated to an owner.
So it doesn't necessarily have
to have an owner. But it could,
however, in the second part, we
can see that there is an
essential piece. So if we were
to design the bicycle class, so
that it had more components,
such as frame parts, these would
be called composition. Because
the part itself is useless
without the parent, or some kind
of a component that really has
no purpose apart from a bicycle.
Now you can make the argument
that some things like a wheel
here at the bottom, a wheel can
exist without the bicycle, it's
not very useful, but you can
imagine it. So it's kind of a
fine distinction when you talk
about composition and
aggregation. So in the case of
our application, I chose to use
aggregation here in the UML
diagram, you can see that a
track is part of a album. And so
the album has a property called
a list of tracks. So you could
argue that tracks can't exist
without an album. But you can
release a single I think so I
chose aggregation to represent
this in the UML diagram. Now, if
I started to ask for new
features in your app, the first
thing I would do is to send you
to the drawing board. And I
would say, let's add some
comments. And before we even
start coding, I want you to draw
the picture of how we're going
to handle these. And so we would
add a comments table to the
database, wouldn't we? And you
can see that we would have a
foreign key so that each comment
is associated with a track. Now
the track can have multiple
comments. So that's a one to
many relationship. So that's
what the tables would look like
if we were to make an ER diagram
for a comments part. Now in the
design for the application
itself, we would have an
associated UML diagram. And so
you can see almost the same
thing happening here. In this
case, I used a little black
diamond to indicate that
comments are a composition
relationship to their track. The
reason I chose composition was
because if you were to delete a
track from the system, the
associated comments would have
nowhere to go. And so a comment
should not exist apart from its
parent should not exist apart
from a track. So on the left
side, you can see that the
relationship between a track and
an album is labeled as
aggregation. That's because a
track could exist apart from an
album. However, on the right
side, I have labeled the
comments and tracks as a
composition relationship.
Because a comment should not
exist unless there is an
associated track. Now let's add
some more features. Let's say if
I were to add users and artists
to the tables. So you can see
that now a comment is associated
not using a string
For the user name, but an entire
class called user, so the user
can have maybe a login screen
could have a password could have
a bio, I don't know what you
would put in a user class. But
you can imagine all of the
things that go into a user, same
thing goes with the artist over
here. So instead of just using a
string, and saying that this
album belongs to the Beatles, we
could say that the artist has
multiple pieces, we can have a
little biography on the artist,
we can have a list of all albums
that the artists have has. And
so your your application starts
to grow, adding new classes that
are related to each other. So
then associated with that would
be the database. So the
associated ER diagram shows all
of the tables, and the
relationships and the foreign
keys that go with them. Now, by
the end of this course, I'm
going to ask you to create some
challenge activities. And those
are going to include things like
comments. So keep this in mind,
because we're going to see that
soon. In the next video, I'm
going to show you how to do
something called compound
queries, which is really two
queries kind of combined into
one action. So we'll do that
next.
Hi, and welcome to another
tutorial for our SQL database
application. So in this part of
the tutorial, we're going to go
to this section here called
compound queries. So we're going
to combine one result with
another. And we're just going to
refactor some of the code that
we developed in earlier
sections. So here's the design
that I'm referring to. So on the
left, we have the UML. And we
have the right, which is an ER
diagram. So we're going to be
modifying our model here. So you
can see about the last line in
the album properties is a list
of tracks. And so that's what
we're going to implement here in
this video. My name is shad
Sluiter, and I teach software
development at Grand Canyon
University. So welcome to class,
make sure that you check out
study coding.org To get the full
playlist and other courses as
well, I want you to come along
and become a software engineer
just like many of my students.
So just to be clear, the
application that you see is
going to look the same. So I got
the same actions going on here.
So when I select an album, I
have the tracks appear in the
second table on the application
form. So we're not changing the
look, we're just changing the
design. So let's get started in
the code. So the first place I
want to go is into the album's
class. And some time ago, I left
a note here that said, we're
going to later make a list of
tracks as part of the properties
here. And so that's what we're
going to do right now. So I want
to show that we have a list of
type track, and we're going to
use the get and set properties
and make it public. The next
part we're going to adopt here
is the album's Dao. So I've
collapsed all of the methods
that are in this class just so
that we can get a summary of
what we've made. So you can see
we have a method to get all the
albums to search for albums by
title to add an album. And then
we have two different selectors
at the bottom one is getting the
tracks for the album. And then
the second item here was also
forgetting tracks using a join
statement. So joining meant that
we could have a flexible number
of columns. So we're going to be
modifying the the get all albums
method here. And we're going to
use the get tracks for album as
a kind of a secondary helper. So
let's get into the get all
albums. So you can see that I'm
inserting right below the place
where we just fetched a new
album, I'm going to now add the
tracks property to this variable
called a so a dot tracks equals,
and then I can go to another
method in this in this class
here to get those tracks. So get
tracks for album is another
helper methods we're going to
use. Now the part that's missing
here is that it's expecting a
number. So let's type in A, and
let's get the let's see, I think
it's the ID number. Yes, it is.
So if we provide the ID number
for this album, we should be
able to get all the tracks and
then add them to the list of
things that we're returning. So
that's a small change here. But
it's going to allow us to save
all the tracks at the same time
we fetch the album. Now that
we've returned all the tracks as
well as the album, we can modify
what we do in our form one. So
here we are in form one, I'm
going to the very top, and I'm
going to add one new item. So
I'm going to save a Global list
of albums that we can refer to
after it's been fetched. So
we'll make a list called albums.
Now, just to prove to you that I
can use this list, I'm going to
define it here in line 21. And
I'm going to fetch all the
albums and assign it to this
list. And then the next step
down, let's assign the data
source for the control to the
list. So it's an intermediate
step. We've just kind of a
temporary placeholder. But we
can fetch this again without
going
Add to the database and you'll
see that in a second. Now there
is an important difference
though. So the album's now
contain a property that includes
the list of all tracks, so we
don't have to go back later and
fetch those again. So the next
section I want to work on is
down here in the data grid view,
click an event item. So when we
click an event, in the current
stage, what we have right here
are several lines that go back
to the database to get the
tracks. And that's where we're
going to change the main point
of this lesson. So right now it
is going to the database to get
its values. And we're just now
going to use the list that we
have stored in memory. So I have
to know that on line 46, I know
which row number was clicked. So
that also tells me which album
was clicked. So let's use that
to our advantage. So I can wipe
out any reference to the
database now. And its next is to
just get the item that was
clicked. And so albums Add Row
clicked. And that tells me which
row number of which album it is.
And I'll just swipe the tracks
from that list. It's already
been saved there. So I just
reference it. So let's see if
that works. I'm going to run the
app now. Alright, here we go. So
I'm going to choose Load albums,
and let it fetch from the
database. There's my list. So
let's go ahead and click
something like help and see what
we get. So we can see that one
of the tracks has help and the
other two, so Abbey Road, what
does it contain, it shows come
together, and here comes the
sun. So we've got ourselves a
list that appears to work the
same as it did before, but we've
just refactored it. Now one
final word about doing compound
queries. So you can see here in
the album's Dao, I am referring
to the database twice. So in the
second time, when I go and get
the tracks, I am going through
another loop. So the more times
you add a request inside of a
request, your database or
response time will become less
and less. So be careful how many
times you are calling references
to another table because you are
growing exponentially in the
complexity of your for loops. So
if you select something in a for
loop, and then another thing
inside that for loop, you're
going from squared to cubed into
quadrupled and the power so you
can really slow down your
database with these kinds of
reactions. Now there are ways to
make this work better, including
indexing, or if you go to a
different structure altogether,
instead of SQL, you could work
with maybe a no SQL database,
such as MongoDB. But that's for
another course. And so we're
trying to learn SQL right now.
So we're going to do some
deletions from the database. And
also I promised you that we're
going to have a video player. So
we'll maybe we'll sneak that in
next time. See us soon.
Hi, and welcome back to another
tutorial for our SQL database
application. In this tutorial,
we're going to learn how to use
the delete statement. So this is
the contents of all of the items
in the course that we've looked
at so far. So we're on the
second to last item, which is
deleted. My name is shed
Sluiter, and I teach software
development at Grand Canyon
University. I'm glad you're here
in class, and you too can become
a professional web developer,
you can find all the courses
that I teach at study
coding.org. So make sure you
sign up there and get a great
career. So let's take a look at
how we're going to finish off
this tutorial. So this is the
app as we have it right now I'm
going to select something like
Yellow Submarine. And you can
see the new item that I have
below is now a button that says
Delete selected. So let's click
there. And I get a results says
one item was deleted. Click OK.
And it blinks off. Now if I
choose yellow submarine again,
you can see that the item is
deleted. So that's what we're
trying to do is delete a track
will save deleting an album for
another part. But we're trying
to delete tracks in this part.
So there are several steps we're
going to accomplish. First of
all, we're going to add a button
to the form, then we're going to
add an item to the Dao. And then
when we're all done there, we
should have our application
working. So let's start here
with the form. And I'm going to
just drag a button in. So we're
going to put a button in right
below the table. And let's put
the text on the button to say
delete selected track. Now this
isn't the most fancy user
interface you've ever seen. But
remember, our focus here is
about building a SQL database.
Alright, so we got the button
here. So let's double click it.
So now we need to get in this
event, we need to get whatever
was selected in the table and
then call a delete command. So
I'm going to scroll up here and
I'm going to grab some code that
will come in useful here. What I
want to do is make sure that I
have the number that is selected
in the grid. So this here, this
row clicked is the value that
I'm going to use
Oops, I'm gonna copy that. And
let's bring it down to our last
item. So I want to make sure
that the date of it grid view, I
think it's number two gets the
item. So let's, let's put in the
grid two, and then we're going
to uncomment the line, just to
see if this is working. Let's
test it out. All right, we got
the app up and running. Let's go
ahead and choose Load the
albums. Let's try help. I
believe there are three items
here. So I'm going to pick the
night before and choose Delete
selected, it says you clicked
row one. So let's try this guy
and do it again. And this
doesn't seem to indicate that
it's got the row number correct.
Now, I don't want the row
number, I want the ID number.
And you can see that in my
example, 2728 and 30 are the ID
numbers that I'm interested in.
So I have to fetch the value
from that column, to be able to
get that value, I'm going to go
back up to row 86, it looks like
so there was a statement here
that says we're going to get the
row clicked, and then get the
value out of one of the cells.
So I'll copy him. Alright, so
let's go ahead and paste that
item into there. And it says
here, data grid view needs to
have a more specific name, let's
try number two. And I'm going to
save this as an integer. And
instead of video URL, let's call
this thing Track ID. Now I've
got almost everything there
don't I know this is a string,
this needs to get out of the
way. And I want to have the
cells at column zero. So all of
that now tells me to fetch the
ID number out of the grid, we
still have a problem, though, we
have an underline. And let's
check to see what it says. It
says here, you're trying to
convert something called an
object to an integer. So what
that means is, there's no
guarantee that column zero has
the integers in it, there might
be an integer there, if I saved
it in the database as an
integer. So I'm going to assume
that it's there. And what I need
to do then is tell it, we're
going to cast the whatever comes
out of that row and put it into
an integer type. So there's a
potential for issue that the app
could crash because, well, the
database might not have actually
an integer there. But remember,
this is trying to make this as
fast as possible. No error
checking really going on. Now
I've got this integer here,
let's see if it actually is an
integer, we'll put a message box
in just to confirm that that's
actually what we're getting, I'm
going to put in a message box
that says ID of track equals and
then we're going to put in the
track ID value. Let's test that
out. Once again, the apps
running, let's go ahead and
choose an album. And then after
I have the album, I'm going to
pick something. So let's select
somebody like Ticket to Ride and
then click the Delete button. It
says you are on row two clicked
OK. And it says Track ID is 30,
which seems to indicate correct.
So now it's time to advance
where we can take that ID 30 and
ask the database to delete that
value, delete that track number.
So in the next row down, I'm
going to call upon our Dao. And
we're going to call the delete
method. So let's make an
instance of the Dao. And then
we're going to make a new call
to it that doesn't exist yet. I
want to save the results of that
as an integer. And I'm just
going to call it result because
I think it's the number of rows
deleted, but I'm not sure I'll
test it out. So I'm just going
to call it result, I'm going to
be equal to the DAO dot. And
I'll invent a new method called
delete track, and provide it
with the ID number of the track.
So now that we're done with
that, you're going to see that
there's an underline, not quite
finished yet. But we do need to
confirm something happened. So
let's put another message box in
to say the result. So what are
we going to do with this delete
track, it doesn't exist, as you
can see. So if I hover over the
error, you're going to say there
is no method found there. So
let's ask for it to generate a
result for us. So when I click
that link, it should go into the
other class and create that
method. For us. It's probably
not implemented, but at least
it's there. Let's go see what
happens. So I'm gonna go over to
the album's Dao and open it up.
And you can see that I have the
previous methods here, I have
get search add, and here it is
delete track. So this is brand
new, it returns an integer, and
it accepts something called the
track ID. We're on the right
track. Now let's see if we can
add the code to make this
happen. So let's go to the
previous method, which was
adding a new album. So we're
going to copy most of the code
in there, and then insert it
into our current method, which
is for deleting, we'll make some
modifications, obviously, and
then we'll make the SQL
statement work. Alright, I'm
gonna go through here and clean
things up. So first of all, the
statement where it says, we are
going to do the insert, that
obviously is wrong. So I'm going
to just delete that for now. And
then I'm going to have one
parameter instead of four or
five of them. So I'll delete all
those
We're going to say instead of
new rows, I'm going to call that
a result. And then when I'm
done, I'm going to return the
result. So what do we have to
do? Now we have to add a SQL
statement to make this happen.
And after the SQL statement,
we're going to have to modify
the parameter that's going to be
used, which is probably called
Track ID, so use an app Track ID
for the placeholder. Now the
only thing left here is to go
figure out the SQL statement.
And we're going to get some help
from the other part of our
program, the my admin tool. So
now I'm looking at the table
here for the tracks. I'm at PHP
myadmin. Again, I'm going to
come down to the very last item
where it says, Yellow Submarine.
So I'm going to select the
yellow submarine, and then the
Delete option here at the
bottom. And it says here, I'm
going to execute this statement.
So this here is the exact code
that I need. So I'm going to
right click on that, and copy
whatever was in there. Now just
to test it out, I'm going to
choose Yes. And it looks to me
like it worked. It says Yellow
Submarine is gone. So I got that
code. Now I can switch back into
my application and right between
the little quotation marks, I'm
going to paste it. So here is
the code. So how do you do a
sequel Delete? Well, here's the
answer we do delete from, and
then it has the table name. And
you have a WHERE statement where
the tracks ID equals something.
So this 43 worked for one
instance. Now I'm going to
change that to be a track ID as
a placeholder. And then I'm
going to associate that
placeholder value with what was
passed in here. So this should
all work hopefully. Now
remember, all these backticks
are kind of optional. I'm just
going to leave them in for now
because that's what MySQL seems
to like, down at the bottom.
What do we got here? We got one
more error, return return, How
about how about if we change
that to result? That might make
more sense. Okay, so we're going
to execute this delete
statement, we're going to
capture the results and send it
back. And hopefully we get a
delete. Now I just deleted the
yellow submarine and I want to
put it back. So I'm just going
to come back and do a SQL
statement. And I have this
prepared where it's inserting
new items. So I'm going to go
and it looks to me like it, put
it back in. Now we're at row 44.
So you might have to recreate a
track if you've deleted them
all. Alright, it's time to run
this. Let's go ahead and click
the green button for our app.
And let's see if we can do a
delete. All right, here we go.
I'm going to load the albums.
And I'm going to try a Yellow
Submarine again. So let's go
down to Yellow Submarine. There
he is. So I've got it selected.
Choose delete this, it says you
clicked row zero. It was ID 44.
And the result was one, so it
must be one row deleted. Now
let's see where did it go? Did
it go away? Let's try yellow
submarine again. Let's try it
again. And delete it says zero
ID 44. This time the result was
zero. So you can see that my
user interface is not quite
updating. The second time I
tried to delete this, it says
there was nothing to delete. So
I believe it was taken out of
the database. But the
application on the screen the
user interface didn't show the
results. So let's make a quick
tweak. So back here in form one,
I'm going to make two changes.
First of all, I'm going to erase
the data source for grid two. So
it'll erase everything that's
there from the screen. Then I
want to reload the albums
because one of the tracks has
been deleted, and we need to
refresh that. So we'll do
another call to the database to
fetch everything. Alright, with
those two steps, we should be
able to see some results. Now
I'm going to put in another copy
of Yellow Submarine just so I
can delete it. So I'm going to
switch back. And let's try the
SQL statement. And let's see, do
I have that copied somewhere.
And so I've got this insert
statement to copy and then I'm
gonna get choose go. So now
we're up to track number 45.
Let's see if we can delete that
track. So switching back, I'm
going to run the application
this time and let's go and try
to delete Yellow Submarine. So
I'm going to choose Load
everybody.
And let's go down to one of my
tracks. Let's try a Yellow
Submarine. And then I go down to
select the yellow submarine and
delete it. It says zero track 45
And the result was one this time
as you can see, it deleted the
screen and emptied out the
tracks. Let's try a Yellow
Submarine. And this time it is
empty. So it looks like the
Delete worked. Now in the next
video, we're going to talk about
more features that I'm going to
leave for you as a challenge so
that you can develop your skills
and make this app complete. See
you soon
Hi, and welcome back to another
tutorial for the SQL database
application. In this video, we
are finally at the end, and I'm
going to show you some of the
new features that you're going
to do. So here's the table of
contents of all of the things.
And we are at the last item,
which is called future features,
which means you get to do them.
My name is shad Sluiter, and
I've been your guide here
throughout the course I teach
software development at Grand
Canyon University. If you'd like
to get the full course on
databases or on web development,
or on mobile, go to my website
at steady coding.org. And you
can get a full degree almost
just online. Okay, so let's talk
about some of the unfinished
business now that is left in
this application. You can see on
the screen here that I have
completed a whole bunch of
things without the video being
on let's take a look at what
they are. And I'm going to
challenge you to do them. And if
you can't, I'll give you some
source code that you can look at
and learn from. So what did we
do. So what I've done is I've
added some features such as
edit. So if I choose yellow
submarine and choose Edit, you
can see that the form over here
is filled in so that way we can
change things. So let's say if I
want to change the year from 68,
to 69, you can see that the
Update button shows that there
was one row updated, and so the
updated item or appears in the
list. Let's take a look down
below here. So if I choose Help,
and let's try editing help,
let's go to the Edit Selected
button. And you can see that we
have the same thing down below,
we can either add a new track,
or in this case, edit one. Let's
say I want to change this to
track number 13. And I'm also
going to change the album. So
you can see that they dropped
down. What would happen if this
actually went with Abbey Road,
let's click the Update. And
it'll give me a status message.
And then if I choose Abbey Road,
you're gonna see help now
appears in the wrong album. Well
better change that back so that
it's going back to the help
album.
The other choice is the delete
button. So if I wanted to get
rid of somebody, I could just
push the delete button and away
it goes. Now obviously, there's
some more code that's involved
here. So let's take a look
behind the scenes to see how
this works. I've repurposed the
input forms so that it not only
can add a new album, and put
down here a new track, I also
have the ability to update and
edit those things. So let's look
in the DAO, which is where a lot
of these SQL statements are.
That's where all of the SQL
statements are stored. So we've
got some new features here. So
you've got an update, you got an
ADD, what else is there is a
delete, there is an update at
track and get a new track. So
all of the operations, the
entire CRUD operations, which is
create, update, read and delete,
they all require some special
coding. So those are going to be
found inside of the new methods.
Let's take a look at one of
them. So for instance, update
track. So when I do an update
track, I'm expecting to get a
object for the new track. And
then an updated item number.
Let's see what we do with those
inside of this method. So here
is the statement. That's the key
part that says, I'm going to run
a SQL statement which is
updating. So I copied this
directly out of the MySQL admin
tool. And we're going to be able
to adapt it just like we did
with the other items in previous
tutorials. So we go through
here, and we add all the
parameters. And I get an updated
rows number which tells me how
many rows were changed and then
return it. Same thing is going
to hold true here with the
updated album. So I have two
items, I say give me a new
album, give me the album ID that
is going to be changed. And then
when I go through here, I get
the same idea. So I'm changing a
bunch of albums. So there's a
little bit more code that I'm
going to let you look at, let's
try editing a selected. So
you're gonna see here that when
we click that button, it's going
to fill in a whole bunch of text
values with the properties of
the item that is being edited.
And then I'm using a checkbox
called editing, to be able to
tell if the form should be used
to update an item, or to create
a brand new one. And so if it's
an update, then we're going to
set this property to true, and
then set the label on the form
to be the item number or the the
track number. And so there's
some tricks to making form have
two purposes. So the best way
maybe now to learn is to look at
the source code for the project
as it is. And of course I'll put
that on the course at study
coding.org. So you can take a
look there. So if you'd like to
learn how to build more
sophisticated apps that are more
web based instead of just forms
like this is that's probably
where you're going to get a real
job. Jobs are going to be
probably full stack developer
and those kind of target
keywords. But I hope you
You get a job. And if you do,
I'd like you to let me know. So
you can contact me on LinkedIn
or at my YouTube channel. So
it's been a great experience
with you. I hope you learned a
lot. We'll see you in the next
course.